um the the one drafting attorney we have
left that's been here for more than 15
minutes so
that didn't it just didn't happen so I
I'm sorry about that I that's okay I
can't I fought the law and the law won
so
um literally
but yeah the
so just to just to reiterate the
the parts that were not applicable to
group one and the parts that were not
applicable to group two I.E teachers
firemen the things that should be there
the language cleanup if you will
um that's all been there
the we changed the 85 percent to 100 I
saw yeah yep the request from
representative McGuire was added at the
uh on that portion and
that was pretty much it the rest like
that was the only substantive change was
her request and then the rest was
language cleanup so
um
seems
it seems as though they did what we
asked I didn't I couldn't see any other
I didn't see anything else myself other
than the Bolding part which you know
it's just what I wanted so it doesn't
really matter so
yes representative McGuire
read the amendment and on pay part one
page one
on line six and seven
the original line said
that the this expands what was in the
draft amendment to include the
calculations of earnable compensation
and average final compensation which is
okay because that's they're different
and then it says cannot be reduced
the previous version was cannot be
changed
well perhaps
they misinterpreted it but the amendment
that I looked at did specifically say
changed
and so I want to make sure that we know
what we're doing with this because that
that it I think that's significant
the version of the amendment that we
were working from at the subcommittee
meeting
had changed
this has reduced and whether or not
representative Pearson meant reduced
that wasn't what it it said so if that's
what what we want to do that's one thing
that's kind of an awkward phrasing going
to agree the idea because it says the
calculation cannot be reduced from you
know like I never heard that before I
mean you get what they're talking about
I can show you the first draft in print
it says reduced
it does yeah I'm looking at the second
draft I'm looking at the second draft
too Carolyn it does say reduced on mine
all right fine I I misinterpreted that's
right the point still stands like the
point's still significant that is a
that's one of the significant policy
decisions that this includes it's not
just the elimination of the table and uh
consolidating everyone into the a vested
category essentially we're saying that
we won't change or we won't reduce
a pension after three years which
implies that there's a essentially a
three-year probationary period where it
can be changed and then it can't
so if that's what policy if that's the
policy we want to adopt
um
great I mean I think yeah it's a policy
decision but it will mean that if we if
any changes are ever made
due to another collapse in the market or
whatever so that we have to make changes
it will it will be a a pretty clear
and obvious non um you know violation of
of of a promise the other promises were
the other the promise is that the
people who have been testifying were in
other documents they weren't in law
but this is a specific promise in law
that we're making so we should be aware
that we're doing so
and good luck
so one of the one of the things with
that is that if if the word reduced is
is modified to changed
then this bill can't happen because
after this is a 10-year plan so after
three years the plan would shut off
so that that won't work
yeah I'm I'm just thinking about the
conversation that we were having earlier
um if if the plan is written in law
which it is I mean the agreement is
written in law when when the person
signs on uh to their personal pension
plan
and
if you're correct in saying that that
plan cannot be retroactively changed
which seems reasonable to me that
provision may also be in conflict with
with that idea because this would seem
to insinuate that we could retroactively
change that in year two so I agree with
you that so that is a in Most states
they have the ability there is a little
bit of a probationary period that exists
so this addresses two elements of that
it doesn't address into reference
representative McGuire's point in the
event of an issue
um the the contributions that meant that
the workers have to pay in is not
protected that can be adjusted and
modified
um the areas of the cap can be modified
so this this is just saying that you
know when you're when you're coming to
work and you think that
okay this is the duration of time that I
need to do and this is how they figure
that out
that that element of it really should be
locked in in people's minds because
they're agreeing to take service under
this idea and this is how we got into
this entire mess in the first place yeah
so what this is saying is that you know
what
because we have a longer than average
vesting period whereas for the six New
England states vested five years we we
require 10. this provides some stability
to say you know what under traditional
concepts of vesting
if we can go back and change your
conditions at nine years that's the
exact problem we're in right now I don't
want to repeat that problem again in the
future so this is this is a the the
three-year ask here is a bit of a it's a
reputation repair it's a credibility
repair on the part of the state to say
you know what after you've given three
years of commitment to us we're going to
give commitment to you and say
that you're you're in so but but well
not even necessarily you're in because
you're not vested but you're you know
we're not going to change your average
we're not compensation rates exactly
sorry I shouldn't have said yeah
clarification
um
that that's the that's the idea there
it's it's a it's we you've committed now
we've committed now again like I said
before in last work session you know
these are careers they're not jobs
I'm not
pushing or advocating for us to go to a
five-year vesting that involves like a
lot of money and a lot of other things
so just just for sake of time can I stop
you for that sure
um any questions from anybody on the
committee at this point either about
this three-year thing or comments
concerns anything because we don't have
a tremendous amount of time this morning
yeah representative Davis
I was I
I'm new on the committee and all of this
stuff is very new to me I was just
wondering
this is well thought out and well
written I was just wondering why it took
so long just to straighten it out
well you have um political wins blow in
a different direction sometimes
and
um that's the most neutral answer I can
give you
uh difference differences of opinion and
philosophy uh as to when lines should be
drawn
um so there are people who believe that
drawing the line at the point of
vestment was a completely fine thing to
do and retroactively doing this and
there are people who think that that's
retroactive law and shouldn't have been
done and you know benefits shouldn't be
changed so the kind of debate has waged
over the years as to what was
appropriate and what wasn't appropriate
another the other thing too with this
two representative is that there was
when when this all came to happen there
was a bit of a national craze going on
all the states were looking at it we had
some really bizarre media hype that
surrounded it and now that we have I
guess the benefit of some some 2020
Vision looking back over the last decade
there are other states that have gone
back and made changes and reverted back
to Old benefits because they they got
caught up in the craze too and realized
hey we just went too far we just went
too far so
there's I think there's an element of
that where you can just you can look at
what you did and go eh you know what
this we had some unintended consequences
here as well
anybody else
uh yes representative true and then
representative uh thank you Mr chair so
uh on uh
on the on my on the not reduced after
three years line page one five through
seven
um
that is only that's only referring to
the people affected by the entire change
the 1700 people no no that would be
everybody
so that's the people affected by the
change the people who were in The Old
system and the people in the new system
so post 2012 after 2012. is only
speaking to group two
it is only speaking to group two I
believe
yeah
um RSA 100 because it is specific to
those two paragraphs yeah so yeah
only group two uh that's the art well as
far as I can tell I mean let me let me
dive in here a little bit just to see
this may let me look that up Chris
no it would it would apply to both
groups because it's because as it's
written it's the Roman numeral which
which encompasses the
um once this goes into effect though
yeah yeah because it because there's no
sub paragraph oh there's no sub
paragraphs you're right no it's just
straight up the eight there
it would be very peculiar for the state
to have to have a different definition
for Investing For one group over another
that that that would be weird
so well then once again yeah this would
apply to both and and the vesting
component of it I mean that that's how
we've been functioning
um it's just never been written in law
all of our calculations everything's
based off of 10 years for as far as the
vesting is concerned the um fact that
your average final compensation and
earnable compensation definitions so
what qualify like what monies you make
qualify towards going towards your final
benefit and then once we've run the
calculation what that average final
benefit is going to be where you know we
can run the calculations based off of
that final amount that you've earned
um those things can't be changed after
three years they're they're locked in
place so if we say we're going to take
your best five years all right and you
know a few other little caveats in there
nuts against too much detail that can't
change and once we've calculated what
that number is for you that can't change
either so those two things but there are
many elements that can yes this is just
specific to two parts of it right so
they can change so right now
firefighters pay and 11.8 percent of
their own money into the system if a
future legislature wanted to come back
and say everybody now has to pay in 12
or 7 or whatever it would be this
wouldn't affect those people in that way
we could still change their rates
um that they have to pay in
thank you Mr chairman so uh one of the
things that I think is we should be
conscious and cognizant of is that we
are creating a record here
it's not only the document that we're
producing but these deliberations are
part of the record okay and that's
something that that if it ever came to a
suit lawsuit
that the court looks back and sees how
the how the the record was created and
and what the record specified so as long
as we're clear about what we're doing
and why we're doing it
um and and that we are not didn't
stumble into it oh you know we'd if we'd
ever thought about that we wouldn't have
done it that way or we would have done
some other way no we are consciously
doing this this is what we want to do
this we're making this policy decision
on behalf of the you know starting the
the full committee deliberations uh and
as long as we're clear and I am that
this is what we want to do we want to
lock it in
I'm good to go
well my feeling on my perspective on it
is
if we're if we're going to push this
legislation forward at all then we said
we shouldn't have done it before and if
we shouldn't have done it before I'm not
sure why we wouldn't limit it from
happening again in the future
um the two seem to me to go kind of hand
in hand
um so from that perspective I'm I'm
comfortable with it I'm always cognizant
of the fact that something catastrophic
can happen in the future and this might
have a ramification for that
um
including for the whole system but then
again a future legislature can always
come out and take this out if they want
to so I mean it's repealable it's not
constitutional law it's not
constitutional law it's statute so it
can be repealed
um
so I mean there's always that part of it
too in our ever-changing world of of
politics
um
so about halfway through our time
anybody else have anything else that
they would like to interject at this
point
any other concerns questions on the
amendments
are seeing none does anybody have
yes okay you know that's fine Chris
we've got 15 minutes you can have 10 you
can have 12 of them
um
could you review the policy changes
policy changes first off you're getting
that reduced after three years of
service that we just saw okay
um you're getting on page eight
is it eight was that the one Steve
there's definitely one there
where's the age yeah the it's the eighth
would be yeah there it is the concession
of the of the pension cap
from 85 to 100 of the members final
average compensation there's more than
just that though so it's the 85 percent
backed back back to 100 but there's also
the the fact that the pension cap is now
encompassing eight years of people that
were not under any pension cap before
so and then it's establishing that
pension cap at 125 000 and then it's
giving an annual increase of 1.25
percent
and that just that accounts for
inflation so that the um the pension cap
doesn't get stagnant
uh it doesn't mean that anybody would
ever make that amount that's up to
municipalities they can they can make
that determination
um so you're getting that uh you're
getting the rollback of the table
um so that people who are in that
transitional period who had their
um
benefits changed the annual multiplier
change from 2.4 to 2.3 to 2.2 to 2.1
they're every year that's getting
repealed for a different group of people
back to the 2.5 and the old calculation
table that they were hired under so
you're getting that I feel like I'm
forgetting one thing
if we're getting something
as far as policy goes yeah
no because the rest of it's all the
changes other than um
just also too it's not a policy change
but it is in essence a concession that
the anti-spiking provisions are all
remaining sure when those folks prior to
09 were not covered
with the anti any anti-spiking provision
so the 2001 to 2009 folks if we were
going to do a full restore back to what
they were hired under in theory they
should have no pension cap but the
pension caps and the anti-spiking
provisions are all being left in place
to because we don't again as you said we
don't want to repeat bad mistakes in
both directions here
so as far as I can see we have two
options before us as a subcommittee
um we can either
recommend the adoption of this amendment
for the executive session this afternoon
because we are executing this bill one
way or another at one o'clock this
afternoon it's scheduled for that so we
can either bring this recommendation
forward or the bill in its original form
will come forward to the executive
committee and we'll be debating that
original bill without this amendment
um
does anybody see that differently Tony
son all right
yeah I understand I'm not I don't have a
vote but yeah no no I was just looking
for you for clarification also
procedurally the only way you would not
debate the original bill is that if
someone on the committee immediately
moves this the amendment and then you
don't have to have two discussions
exactly right so if if the
subcommittee thinks that we should move
this amendment
um I will be moving that Amendment at
the at the executive meeting
that's pretty standard procedure that
subcommittee chair makes the motion okay
does anybody have any concern with
moving this amendment Chris yeah yeah no
you had your hand up before yeah I'm
down to four thousand
um
is there going to be on the original
bill
it was uh downshifting to the uh to the
political subdivisions yeah so there
isn't on this one this comes out of the
state
right we pay for it and and that is do
we get a physical note on that not yet
so this is where we sit as far as the
fiscal component of this concerned this
amendment
um yeah has to pass and it would
allocate 25 million dollars okay if that
stands if nobody changes that
um any of the 25 million dollars that
isn't spent to meet the requirements of
the bill would be downshifted to
municipalities to lower their rates
however this bill still will have to go
to finance and finance will have a
finalized
um fiscal note and they can make an
adjustment to it if they choose so if
the fiscal note comes in at let's say
just for for ease 200 million dollars
they can down they can amend the bill to
say 20 million dollars over the next 10
years and then that's what we would pay
in there'd be less obviously
downshifting to the municipalities for
rate reduction at that point but that's
something that that Finance can do if
they choose to
does that make sense
anybody else
also representative true understand that
it's a policy problem that we have with
the rules of the retirement system it's
not that they are unwilling to give a
fiscal note for this right now they are
prevented until this passes yeah we've
got to get this out of our committee
well through this committee or through
the house there's been some discussion
as to
um internally talking to Marty about
that
they're going to try to see if they can
loophole around this once the committee
passes it to start that process but
technically it has to pass the house so
it's it's a week but even still Finance
should have it be able to hang on to it
for long enough to get the fiscal note
and then they can be good decision but
either way whatever anyone does it's
terminally funded it's terminally funded
yes
would anybody like to make a motion as
to whether or not to adopt this
amendment
Representatives I'll make a motion of
ought to pass okay do you have a second
on that representative Gerhard thank you
you guys want to say anything about it
I think it's all pretty much been
covered so but like I said I'm very
impressed with this and finally happy to
see something that comes through that
really helps people in the retirement
system
yeah
hopefully it reestablishes the state's
credibility awesome
representative true
um
I think it is it is definitely an
improvement
over downshifting 10 million dollars to
the uh
to these uh towns
I'm not saying what I'll say in
committee
but I support the amendment as being an
improvement
okay very good
representative Schmidt did you want to
say anything on it all right I will take
a vote then
um the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment
2023-0483h representative true
representative Schmidt aye
representative Davis
aye representative Gerhard aye and the
chair votes yes so 5-0
all right guys thank you so much for
your work on this we'll bring it to the
executive committee this afternoon at
one o'clock
good morning everyone welcome to Edna
I'd like to
mentioned that
representative Davis is filling in as
our clerk today so be gentle with him
and I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill 457 and calling representative
Bernardi
thank you chair Maguire and committee my
name is JD Bernardi I'm represent
Rockingham 36 which is Hampton Falls
Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow basically the southeast border
from the ocean inward
um I Rise to support HB 457 which is an
act relative to the State Treasury and
pension fund management the key sentence
in the bill and it applies to both
treasury funds and Pension funds is all
Investments and their management shall
be governed by the fiduciary duty to
maximize benefits for the state or the
beneficiaries of the state's trust funds
it's a very simple
clear responsibility
but why present the bill why why isn't
this already being done
well the federal government is changing
the rules on fund management and the
very latest set of rules that they've
modified are the erisa rules the
employee retirement income Security Act
uh basically they have now said that
plans can consider ESG in pension fund
Investments
why is this a problem
why did they need to do this well
because ESG funds traditionally do not
carry the same return as traditional
funds that's why they have to change the
rules we're not maximizing return for
every dollar invested our pensioners are
not getting the full value of their
pension
the CEO of BlackRock is the largest
investment firm managing these kinds of
funds says it's okay to have pension
okay to have your have lower returns for
about 10 years while we achieve broader
sustainability objectives
now we are not alone in this there are
six other states that have already
adopted similar measures West Virginia
Florida Texas Utah Kentucky and Oklahoma
they've either done done this by
legislation or by their treasure taking
action to specify compliance with these
standards
I like to read a note from the Kentucky
attorney general about this issue
while asset managers May review a social
purpose or sacrifice some performance on
their Investments to achieve an ESG goal
investment managers entrusted to make
financial investments for public pension
systems must
be single-minded in their motivation and
actions and their decisions must be
solely in the interest of the members of
the benefit members and beneficiaries
and for the exclusive purpose of
providing benefits to the members and
beneficiaries
to do otherwise risks breaching clearly
established statutory contractual
fiduciary duties
it is the opinion of this office that
stakeholder capitalism and environmental
social governments investment practices
then introduce mixed motivations to
investment decisions are inconsistent
with the law governing fiduciary duties
and by
owned by Investment Management firms to
public benefit public pension plans
in addition to that there are 16 other
states that are taking up similar
legislation
um and several of the attorney generals
have also written a letter to the CEO of
BlackRock I mentioned the largest of one
of these Investment Management firms and
one one or two sentences here in that
letter based on the facts currently
available to us BlackRock appears to use
hard-earned money of our city state
citizens to circumvent the best possible
return on investment as well as their
vote blackrock's public past public
commitments indicate that it has used
citizens assets to pressure companies to
comply with International agreements
that Force the phase out of fossil fuels
increase energy prices Drive inflation
and weaken National Security of the
United States
as I indicated this was signed by 19
attorneys generals of different states
so how is this done well basically the
largest Investment Management firms
BlackRock Vanguard State Street they
have about three quarters the asset size
of the U.S gross domestic product
they have the largest they're the
largest shareholders and 90 of the s p
uh 500 companies
and they force Behavior by voting their
shares
our shares our pensioners shares
they vote them to force the activity
that they want
to have happen I'll give you an example
Exxon
it had three board members up for
renewal
the triumviron of BlackRock being a
Garden State feat voted in three in
environmentalists to sit on that board
instead of oil and gas people
that caused black rock or that caused
Exxon to abandon its leasing
opportunities in Vietnam and Malaysia
who bought them the Chinese Communist
parties
uh
energy firm and who is the largest
shareholder in that company in in the
Chinese firm happens to be BlackRock so
we lose China wins BlackRock wins and
Americans are seeing a Devastation of
our energy investment structure about 90
percent of oil and gas investment has
has been uh dried up in the last few
years our costs go up natural gas costs
go up gas costs go up at the
at the pump
and we see it in our electric rates and
our fuel oil costs and our gas to heat
our home
so their goal is to force Behavior
change
I submit to you that it is your job as
federal and state legislators to decide
what policies we're to have not these
investment firms
the bottom line is we have higher energy
costs and lower rates of Returns on our
Pension funds and a loss of legislative
Authority
so the fix is simple
the short one sentence change to both
the treasurer and the pension fund
responsibilities
um
I might comment on what I saw in the
fiscal note regarding this
there was some concern that that
adopting uh fiduciary duty
responsibility rather than a sole
interest standard may be antithetical to
the the pension fund's responsibilities
I submit they are essentially the same
if anything the sole interest standard
may be a little higher
but I would ask anyone testifying from
that side of the uh of the house do they
have any funds invested in being managed
by BlackRock State Street or Vanguard
are they using ESG in their funds and
are they operating to the detriment of
our pensioners
with that I'll stop and answer any
questions
thank you are there questions
representative thank you you uh
mentioned the uh changes to the Federal
uh fiduciary duty for people that invest
in Pension funds I'd heard about that I
thought they were proposed what is do
you know the status of them in November
that was adopted that said you can now
do it it was a proposal in November of
of last year they it's you may now use
ESG criteria in managing your funds so
instead of having a strict fiduciary
duty now you can intermix your these
additional Concepts okay thank you
Simon thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
um outside of the three main Brokers
that you're talking about
how would we determine whether or not
somebody was using ESG for example over
just straight up fiduciary
responsibility and what are the
repercussions if they don't follow these
guidelines if they do for example use
the SG
uh
I am not sure how we deal with the
repercussions but the folks managing the
funds need to be asking the questions of
of the funds that they're reviewing to
at you know to invest in they have to
specifically ask those kinds of
questions are you using ESG criteria in
making decisions in managing this fund
are you using uh
um diversity Equity inclusion criteria
in managing These funds are you using
anything other than strict Financial
fiduciary duty pecuniary interest
thank you it's an act of responsibility
on these on the part of these folks
thank you representative
representative thank you for being here
today I think that this is a true
concern and something I'm very
interested in
um spinning off of our co-chairs
question when we because I've been
through this personally myself when
you're asking those questions how how
could this lock in to ensure that it's
in writing that they're not using ESG
because even as I've been diving in to
some of my business dealings and asking
I'll get a very delayed answer of 48
hours and then they come back and say no
but I'm not getting a very confident no
we're not using ESG
so how can we strengthen this or ensure
I like where you're going with it I'm
just I want to make sure that it's it's
solid thank you
well it's my understanding that any of
these funds there has to be a full
disclosure of the risks and the benefits
and and normally on page 90 of that in
this in the fine print they'll say oh
well we we do use some of our monies for
ESG purposes but no maybe not all of it
you know so they have to disclose they
have a requirement to disclose and and
so it does require someone to be active
as you as you mentioned you have to ask
these questions you can't just say you
know I trust you you're you're a good
Financial uh firm and you've got a good
track record with us and so you know we
accept your your uh
proposals
okay
thank you madam chair I forgot to thank
you representative
thank you madam chair
I think this is a really good idea but
I'm just wondering if we're going about
it the wrong way in a sense so article
83 allows the general court to
investigate any corporations for
Monopoly
a fraud I mean therefore all just
powered by the state is hereby Grant to
the general court to enact laws to
prevent the operations within the state
of all persons and associations and all
trusts and Corporation corporations
foreign or domestic and the officers
thereof who may Endeavor to raise the
price of any article Commerce Etc et
cetera I think we've pretty much
established that BlackRock has a
monopoly position in many ways I'm just
concerned and maybe
going another route because I just worry
about as we say earlier trying to figure
out they really are engaging in this
kind of activity
so that's my concern well it's
it's clear that they are whether they
have a monopoly activity or not I I it
in aggregate they have have joined with
other investment firms and they
they have uh maybe a little less of half
of all the investment money in the world
um all these firms together they're part
of the the Global Financial Alliance uh
for Net Zero uh and climate 100 group
and and so in aggregate they have that
tremendous marketing power or tremendous
voting power when you when you sit on a
board and and and and you have so the
larger share you're the you collectively
are the largest shareholder you can you
can cause a company to do whatever you
want it to do that's the concern and
that's why these attorney generals and
that's why these other states have taken
action is the the federal government is
right now moving in in a different
direction
um whether or not whether or not you
want to
um have an investigation I mean
certainly yes well this this bill
specifically addresses the investment
policies of the retirement system and
the state treasurer yes uh and I believe
that is within our control so we should
or at least it's within our authority to
make laws that affect them yes we can't
we can't change the federal policy but
we can deal with our Treasures
Investments and we can deal with our
Pension funds investments just like
these other states have have done and
are doing thank you
okay
representative Simon thank you again
Madam chair
um
just hypothetically speaking
um because ESG is a movement and I agree
once again I also agree with whether
you're heading with us I just want to
make sure that we're careful in how we
do it what if every investment firm
starts using ESG my concern is with the
language not just that it would be
um
prioritizing those things but would also
work in concert with
um
would we potentially run out of options
of people to
invest in if that is part of the
language and secondarily if I'm a Madam
chair at the same time have
we looked at other states who are doing
this and it's working have we looked at
their language and compared it to the
language that we're using in this Bill
yes this this language second part first
this language largely came from uh
discussing this with with other states
so we are in in harmony
um and as I mentioned through climate
change 100 and the Global Financial
Alliance for Net Zero and and the
companies involved in that it's around
uh
40 percent of the companies are involved
so sixty percent of them are not and
because the of this issue arising there
are Financial investment firms that are
that are popping up that are saying our
focus is to be a traditional company we
are not getting into this ESG Arena
thank you for the answer
thank you very much representative
Bernardi
I'd like to call Marty Carla
since the treasure isn't here I presume
that your comments also apply to the
treasury
okay thank you
once again
thank you for the record my name is
Marty Carlin representing the New
Hampshire retirement system uh our nhrs
board has not taken a position on this
piece of legislation as yet I provided
some some written testimony as
background that I had um
like to read and then address a couple
of the issues that came up in the prior
testimony
um the nhrs board has had a
long-standing concern about any
legislation that could potentially
impair our fiduciary duty to act in the
best interests of our members
under existing constitutional and
statutory Provisions governing their
Retirement System in New Hampshire as
well as general trust law under the
Internal Revenue code fiduciaries must
follow the duty of loyalty at all times
pursuant to RSA 10a1 a sub paragraph A1
this Duty requires nhrs fiduciaries
including its Board of Trustees and
members of the independent investment
committee to make decisions solely in
the interest of the participants and
beneficiaries
further Eden read the rest of it what's
what's the issue if if you indulge me
please I'll skip the Constitutional
provision but in Lay terms the goal has
always been and continues to be to make
prudent long-term investment that
provide the best chance of meeting on or
exceeding our assumed rate of return
while balancing risk and liquidity this
isn't a new position specific to this
legislation
back in 1987 legislation was considered
that to mandate that the retirement
system divests from companies that did
business in Northern Ireland and failed
to make substantial action regarding the
McBride principles which was a framework
dealing with hiring practices regarding
underrepresented religious groups in
Northern Ireland basically Catholics at
the time external legal counsel warned
nhrs that legislation adding
non-fiduciary factors to the use of
retirement funds would mean that funds
would no longer be used for the
exclusive purpose of providing benefits
but would also be used for the Divergent
collateral purpose of affecting social
or political change
regardless of the how well-intentioned
the goal of this legislation may be our
overall concern is that proposals such
as this whether emanating from the left
or the right of the political Spectrum
have the potential to curtail our
ability to effectively discharge our
fiduciary duty
um so that basically you know I think we
had a similar comments about a China
Bill last year and there's a bill I
believe that Kenny will be hearing next
week but these these comments apply to
as well
um to address a couple of the questions
as a Public Employee Employee Retirement
System nhres is not subject to orisa
there were rules promulgated recently
regarding ESG the pre the prior
administration had rules that banned ESG
so uh with with the um depending on the
leadership in the white house we could
see a lot of fluctuation over the years
and what uh what we're talking about
with ESG
um one one thing about ESG is um
how how is it used we don't have any
funds that we invest in that prioritize
environmental social governance issues
over making as much money as we can for
our members and beneficiaries there are
some funds out there
um that do that we do not invest in that
we don't see that and that we would see
that as a breach of our fiduciary duty
to maximize investment returns for our
members and retirees
BlackRock does have funds that do that
we have we have a substantial stake and
a s p 500 Index Fund managed by
BlackRock so there's no
you know priority given to certain
companies this is the s p and it's it's
probably one of our lowest fee
Investments so even if there were other
managers offering s p index funds we're
not sure if we would be paying more in
fees for that which would arguably
breach our fiduciary duty because we
could get a better deal somewhere else
um and and with ESG
um you know I was looking
um for some some background on on how
that's assessed and I found some uh
there's a paper put out last Fall by
Alec the legislative researchers it's a
non-profit National group of
conservative lawmakers that proposes
model legislation around the country for
various topics and according to Alec
environmental social corporate
governance and other similarly oriented
considerations are pecuniary factors
only if they present economic risks or
opportunities that qualified investment
professionals was treat would treat as
material economic conditions under
generally accepted investment theories
that is what our investment committee
does now we don't prioritize or do that
so you know the the
reference to in concert would if if in
fact 40 percent of managers even
consider these factors that would lower
reduce our investment Horizon by 45
percent and you know in the fees and the
quality of some of the other funds may
not be as as robust as the returns we
can get currently so
um you know that there's there's that uh
that piece to it as well and um
you know uh and finally you know we for
poor proxy eroding proxy voting of our
investments our policy is
um that any ESG proposals to a board
will be considered based on potential
impact on the long-term economic
interests of the company generally we
will abstain from such consideration
absent a clear effect of The Proposal on
Share value
so that concludes my comments
oh thank you despite your saying you're
not taking a position it seems to me
that you're taking a position against
any restriction on the fiduciary duty of
the Board of Trustees and the investment
committee broadly speaking yes if this
if this proposal was put forth to divest
from fossil fuel companies by June 1st
uh you know we would have the same
concerns the other way and and you know
one other
so so specific to this legislation the
board may take a position if it advances
out of committee but as a general
principle any anything that would add
um you know political or social goals on
either end of the spectrum is of concern
okay are there any specific questions
representing a bear and then Gerhart
Marty thank you for being here today so
do you view ESG as a threat
I'm not on the investment committee or
or the director of Investments I you
know
to the extent that it has an impact on
Share value I I think we I can speak for
an HRS that you know that would would be
of concern to us if it's going to reduce
um you know our ability to to earn what
the most we can
foreign
I think the question I asked in the
question you answered are two different
things I think I asked if you thought
ESG was a threat and I think what you
answered is you think it would be a
threat to put this legislation in place
for what you for to meet your fiduciary
responsibilities
we don't have any
um
we don't prioritize or consider ESG in a
vacuum is ESG is inherently good we're a
political on the concept
thank you madam chair
just curious are there any places that
New Hampshire shouldn't be investing
I I you know in the the investment
universe is you know if the federal
government bans investments in certain
countries you know Iran uh you know
certain Chinese companies Russia you
know you know that you know other than
where we are legally prevented you know
by by federal statute from investing in
you know we will look for the best
opportunities most of those are domestic
equities that that's that's sort of our
largest portfolio piece but um you know
you know anything in the legal Universe
we will consider if if it can
meet you know if it can make money for
the members and retirees and and grow
the trust fund
okay one follow-up yes and then
representative thank you
so as far if I remember correctly the
implications well the reason for the
rationale for this bill is more because
of federal pressure might come down upon
investment companies to make certain
decisions so would the retirement fund
be willing to nullify a federal decision
if it interfered with earnings but it
complied with federal law
um the the Federal
Provisions right now are under orisa
which governs private retirement plans
so we're not subject to orisa so any
changes wouldn't affect us if if there
was a a federal law passed
um you know you know we would have to
look at the law and you know if it does
appear to breach fiduciary duty you know
I you know I can't say until we we see a
proposal but the the current changes
alluded to with with orisa plans covered
in private sector and Union retirement
plans not you know low state and local
government plans thank you
representative thank you um kind of
related to that if
um the federal law does change to open
up you know for uh public pension
systems the uh the option to invest in
those so basically loosening the
requirement for investing strictly on a
fiduciary duty basis what is in place
if anything either in statute or
something else
that would require
the investment committee to stay
strictly with uh you know the best
returns with reasonable risk for the
pensioners and the taxpayers I think RSA
1815 one that that proposal that I read
the excerpt from it doesn't it doesn't
prioritize anything above traditional
fiduciary duty and that's a state
statute so we would we would follow that
that would
if if the federal government said you
can if you want to we we read New
Hampshire line and constitutional
provision that you know it would be
um if we were prioritizing
social or environmental goals over
investment returns that we we wouldn't
be able to do that under current the
current statutory framework as it exists
thank you
the questions thank you very much
Christy Merrill and Ryan Hale the
bankers Association
laughs
foreign
testimony you might distribute it soon
good morning Madam chair and honorable
members of the House Executive
Department's Administration committee my
name is Christy Merrill I'm president of
the New Hampshire Bankers Association
and with me today is Ryan Hale he is
Vice President of the New Hampshire
Bankers Association and uh head of
government relations
we represent 38 member banks who employ
approximately 6 000 people in New
Hampshire and we are here today to
provide testimony in opposition to
houseboat 457.
as it's drafted the legislation
prohibits the state treasurer and the
New Hampshire retirement system from
engaging in business with any financial
institution that prioritizes social
political or ideological interests above
or in concert with the traditional
fiduciary duty to maximize Financial
benefit we think that the the fiscal
note on the legislation particularly the
part by the New Hampshire retirement
system really outlines very well I can't
explain it better than they did in terms
that they they describe the language
used in the bill as being vague and
undefined and that will be nearly
impossible to enforce
um as it's been pointed out similar
legislation has been proposed in several
other states around the country
um and in fact Texas passed two bills in
2021 and these proposals prohibited
municipalities from doing business with
banks that had environmental social and
governance policies against the firearm
and fossil fuel Industries
um and I we just wanted to point out a
recent study that was conducted by the
Wharton School of Business at the
University of Pennsylvania and they
outlined that the impact of the
proposals in Texas cost municipalities
an additional 303 million to 532 million
in interest on 32 billion in bonds due
to less competition after several Banks
left the state in that case the
taxpayers of Texas are the one that's
losing their New Hampshire is New
Hampshire's economy is rightly the Envy
of most and banks are proud to be part
of that success they take great care in
reviewing loan application and deposit
accounts and every year Our member banks
support our communities by lending
hundreds of millions of dollars to New
Hampshire businesses and families we've
seen Banks continue to move here however
we're concerned this legislation could
have a chilling effect on that growth in
closing we think it's it houseboat 457
is vague and unenforceable and we would
ask for an experience to legislate but
um I know Ryan wanted to make a few
comments as well
thank you Christy and uh thank you madam
chair and the rest of the committee
um I just also wanted to point out
Indiana is considering a bill very
similar to this um and in their fiscal
note uh they estimate uh that this could
uh that the pension fund in Indiana the
retirement system in Indiana could see
um a 6.7 billion dollars could cost them
6.7 billion dollars over the next 10
years and reduced returns and that's uh
they're managing I think a fund of
around 2.3 billion dollars in assets so
it's pretty significant to the
retirement system
thank you are there questions from the
committee
okay thank you very much thank you
John Carlson
well they're coming up man Jeremy I
asked whether this is going to
subcommittee yes so the pensions of
subcommittee which is which has a clean
slate that will have a clean slate this
afternoon thank you
good morning thanks for the opportunity
to testify today my name is John Carlson
I lead State policy in New Hampshire for
series
organization which works with large
corporations and investors around the
country
I think you'll find some of my testimony
tracks with what we've previously heard
here I'll be pointing to some of those
same studies I'll try to can you get
closer
thank you sorry thank you
uh so I'm providing uh testimony on
behalf of series uh itself the
organization along with its 200 members
of our investor Network which
collectively have about 30 trillion
dollars in assets under management and
the 80 members of our businesses for
Innovative climate and energy policy
Network many of whom have investments in
interest in New Hampshire these are
large corporations like Autodesk Akamai
were then
um Biogen
we have strong concerns over House Bill
457 which is prohibiting the state
treasurer and New Hampshire retirement
system from conducting conducting
business with any financial institution
that prioritize social politicism excuse
me um we don't you don't need to read
your testimony please tell us what the
issues are
um you know as representative Simon
pointed out I think one of the key uh
pieces of language and it is the
prohibition on using any of these
interests in concert with the
traditional Financial fiduciary duty you
know many investors including our
members uh see these considerations as
material to the financial performance of
their Investments now regardless of your
agreement with that statement it
shouldn't be the government's role to
dictate what considerations are allowed
over the considered Judgment of
financial Professionals in the field
um you know adoption of this bill is
effectively going to limit the options
of active fund managers and investment
opportunities for the State of New
Hampshire the retirement system uh
detailed analysis demonstrates this is
going to cost the New Hampshire economy
and citizens to reduce returns
um I my testimony in my written
testimony you'll see I similarly point
to the fiscal note done by the Indiana
State Legislative Services Commission
certainly no Blue State
um
projecting a 6.7 billion dollar decrease
to pension fund returns over 10 years
Texas being one of the few states that
has a similar law in place already
analysis by the Wharton School has shown
uh 300 to 532 million dollars in
additional interests on the bonds result
of restricting the number of banks that
are able to compete for the state's
business so this was a pension fund
managers must consider all risks and
opportunities in order to ensure the
organizations remain profitable over the
long term uh ESG concerns are considered
material and if there is a flaw in that
analysis those funds will have lower
returns over time and the free market
will move Capital away from them a bill
like House Bill 457 is a government
mandate saying that the fiduciary
responsibility to considered Judgment of
financial professionals fiduciary
responsibility these must be breached in
order to put these political concerns
over their own analysis so it urged the
committee to consider those severe
implications and oppose the bill
thank you representative Simon thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question
um when we're just for clarification
purposes when we're talking about
um
this kind of legislation affecting 6.7
billion over I think it was 10 years for
a 2.7 billion dollar fund you're
calculating that predominantly using
bonds that are accessible from Banks
within the state's borders how is that
specifically being calculated so that
was the Indiana State Legislative
Services Commission uh did the fiscal
note I'm not familiar with all of the
aspects of the analysis but certainly
provide you with a copy of it would be
helpful that would be fantastic if you
wouldn't mind
other questions
representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair since you've
already indicated this is going to
subcommittee would you be available for
the subcommittee's deliberations Mr
Carlson I'd be happy to come up yes
thank you
representative gerhardt thank you madam
chair
just curious do you believe that
government has the right to control
corporations
uh I'm not sure that's relevant
okay thank you okay
yes
all right please
thank you very much Abby is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on House Bill
457.
all right seeing none I will close the
public hearing
and open the public hearing on House
Bill 278 call Representative emmerich
and turn the gavel over
thank you madam chair my name is Tracy
Emrick I represent Hampton Rockingham
District 29 my testimony will be very
brief because the the wisdom of the
chair has introduced an amendment which
will wipe out 278 in its entirety so I I
don't see any point in really going into
the details of 278 or of uh answering
questions because it's going to
disappear in the next hearing so thank
you for your time
thank you and thank you for coming
um
Marty
do you want to wait until the
okay sounds great anybody else like to
speak to this before the amendment comes
up
seeing nobody I will close the hearing
on HP 278
and we're on time I will open the
hearing on um
the amendment 2023-0334h
and I recognize representative McGuire
Mr chair members of the committee
the amendment was
wipes out all of House Bill 278 based on
my experience with an identical Bill
last session which would allow
retired police officers to work special
special Duty
on top of the Limited hours specified by
the retirement system
if I'm wrong and the committee wants to
support it this amendment could easily
be in addition to instead of a
replacement for but
I'm betting that won't happen
the what it replaces it with
is a fix for an inadvertent error made
between
everyone in the legislature who didn't
notice something happening OLS and the a
publisher of our law books
and that's what Marty will be here is
here to tell you about
um
so I can't answer that
anything other than this was a request
to the retirement system and OLS to fix
the mistakes that were made
like answer questions about the
about replacing the previous Bill if
necessary
thank you any questions
representative Lucas thank you you
mentioned based on your experience with
a similar bill in the past can you
briefly say what happened uh we killed
it unanimously okay thank you
and it was and it passed the house on
consent no problem
any other questions
saying none thank you
Marty Carlin
thank you and and for the record Marty
Carlin from the New Hampshire retirement
system the Hannah going around is just
the existing statute which would not
change under this amendment but just for
reference if anyone was interested in it
essentially we were alerted to an issue
um by the office of legislative Services
OLS a couple of weeks ago
um that
um in 2013 the paragraph seven was added
to RSA 100 a16 and that added a an
employer report and requirement for
hours worked the in 2011 they created a
weekly limit on how many hours of
retiree could work and then a couple
years later how many people are working
I said well there's no requirement for
them to report data to us so
um the Committee created a bill that we
had the employers had to report monthly
weekly hours for everyone who was
retired and working for them when the
legislature passed that original bill in
uh 2013 it included a five-year sunset
on one one of 19. so the idea was to get
this information for data collection
purposes and then it was going to Sunset
uh in the in the ensuing years between
2013 and 18 this section of the law was
amended um several times along the way
uh employer penalty was added to it uh
for non-reporting a compliance penalty
that we we had the ability to assess and
then in 2018 it was amended generally
and significantly in House Bill 561 it
it replaced the weekly limit with an
annual limit on hours worked the change
of the reporting requirement from
monthly to annually
you know it you know it's a completely
different structure than it was but no
one caught at the time that that repeal
language from the 2013 enactment was
still in the statute you know you know
lurking out there in The Ether
um so the the most recently amended
version of House Bill
561 took effect January 1st of 19 as did
the repeal
okay so I I learned all this from OLS
um and they they heard about it only
because
um the publisher of the bound statutes
for the State of New Hampshire an editor
uh with that West law uh Thompson
Reuters pointing it out to them like hey
I see this conflict what's up with this
and and OLS alerted me to it
um and ols's perspective and they don't
feel like they have the full
jurisdiction to say but the the statute
has been in the law books printed and
the official version of the law every
year since 2019 it was never taken from
the uh taken out of the statute and in
New Hampshire the written bound version
is is the official law even if it
differs from online or you know some
other version so so they believe we have
the have the ability to enforce that you
know report in retirement for the last
three years but the language before you
was drafted by them
um and basically what it does is repeal
the repeal of that section from 2009 19
in a firm the the Amendments along the
way uh in our ability to um to have
enforced that law so I mean this is
really sort of a bureaucratic Kafka
thing that adds a little comic relief to
it for sort of heavy day of bills that
you're going to be talking about but
that that's that's what this is all
about
all right thank you any questions
saying none thank you very much thank
you is there anybody else who wanted to
speak on this amendment
seeing no one I will close the public
hearing
and we are off until 11 15.
okay
let's go into executive session on House
Bill 278
and I'd like to move ought to pass and
break and bring up Amendment 0334h
and I'll
we just heard about that that's simply
fixing
fixing a mistake that nobody noticed the
statute was repeal and we continued to
amend it
and the retirement system continued to
enforce it so we'd like to
clean up our act in this case
and that's all like I want to say about
it representative shewitt
I'll just say that uh yes based on the
sponsor's testimony and Mr Carlin's
testimony stating that this is just
housekeeping I think it's advised
yes it would be embarrassing to have a
repeal but was never noticed floating
around the assistant
all right does anyone else
representative blackis yeah I'm just
wondering
what was the purpose of the original
Sunset and if the idea at that time was
that it didn't need to continue forever
um well why should then why shouldn't we
just repeal it rather than do this
was
at the time we thought we'd only needed
to gather data and find out how how many
people were
we're working after retirement and how
many hours and so forth
representative Schmidt was here at the
time and representative goalie and
representative schuett and we all
thought well we just gather the data and
then Sunset the requirement but it
turned out over the the period that that
happened we started wanting to enforce
the limit and without data you can't
so we somewhat changed the purpose of
the reporting requirement okay thank you
I asked representative true yeah
thank you madam chair
um
so the replace all is all it does is
fixes the error correct
has nothing to do with what the original
bill
wanted to do correct if you are
concerned with the original bill we can
we can discuss that but
like I said it's
it allows retired police to work as much
as they want on special Duty which we
have consistently opposed in other
legislation so I just am making a bet
that that's what the committee would
prefer
I've been wrong before
yes
I'll just add that my recollection of
the
provision that was sunsetted coincides
exactly with the chairs and I would also
Echo that yes this committee has said no
to this original type of proposal pretty
consistently
representative
did you have a correction
you know so it was real purely for
statistical purposes we just sent
somebody a letter says please don't do
it the most recent Amendment does have a
penalty on a retirement for exceeding so
we would have no way to enforce it out
without the report
thank you representative thank you
I I'm going to State my uh understanding
of why this whole thing is in there and
just let me know if it's correct because
I wasn't around when it was put in place
and my understanding is the concern
that um if they you know officers could
retire and then get lots of
pay either special Duty or not then it
might provide an incentive for people to
retire early and then both get a pension
and keep working is that the basic idea
that was one of the main concerns yes
okay thanks
representative Schmidt
so that it
the term hasn't been used today but uh
double dipping is one of the frequent
Banes of our existence on this Committee
in this in this connection
and is that not is this not how the
question represented like us just asked
not the kind of the definition of double
dipping that you you get your you retire
start taking your drawing your pen your
pension and then you go back working
part-time and
we don't like that as I understand it
well yes and this would allow part-time
allow a person to work part-time under
one position and then work as much
special do
or extra duty pay extra Duty as they
wished with no limit whatsoever
um
are essentially back to full time
okay
any other comments
okay then we have the amendment zero
zero three four
excuse me
if that wasn't what I said it's
certainly what I meant sorry about that
okay so to adopt the amendment and the
motion is to adopt the amendment and the
clerks can call the rule
um representative
Simon yes
representative lakis yes
representative Bailey yes
representative true yes
representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
representative Schmidt
yes
representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
clerk votes yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
I think that's a
is there anyone we didn't vote oh in the
chair sorry of course
gotcha no problem that happens all the
time
13 years all right 15-0 the amendment is
adopted and I move ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 278 any further
discussion representative true
representative true were you seconding
or uh okay
is there any further discussion or
comment
all right seeing none we'll uh I think
we should talk a minute to give the
clerk a chance
when ready no rush
foreign
motion the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 278.
representative Simon yes
representative lakis yes
representative Bailey yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard
yes yes
representative Schmidt
yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
in the chair
okay the motion passes 15 to zero is
there any objection to consent
okay we'll put this on consent and I
will write the committee report
it's my convenience and now we only have
20 minutes before the next year
I have a question of the chair so it
does have an FN on on the amendment does
that influence uh whether we can put
leave it on consent or not
even if it was
so that FM doesn't really apply to this
right the amendment it seems the
original Bill had a fiscal impact the
amendment I don't believe does and
um
if they just want to make sure we're
doing it if there's an issue with it the
clerk and the and the speaker will just
pull it off consent and put it in the
regular calendar
yep
it's happened before
okay
we still
together
okay
interactions
a certainly possible
so I'm talking to Lorraine
Elaine
friends yes
patient
s
okay
but
awesome
but that's uh that's minus
thank you
very good
yeah thank you
okay
um
thank you
foreign
beautiful
thank you
yes
um
well that makes sense
thank you
very much
for example
States
but
like yeah
thank you
um
foreign
miracles
um
foreign
and
um
thank you
because
it seemed to me yesterday
welcome back
uh I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 461 and I call Representative
Pearson
thank you madam chair for the record
Representative Steve Pearson Rockingham
District 13 which encompasses
spacetown USA Dairy so 461
461 addresses a problem that
was ex was it one time a one-off issue
in the city of Franklin
and then it happened again
then it happened again
and this is this is something that's
been discussed by the Edna committee for
a couple of years now and
really needs to be addressed before this
goes any further
so what happened
was
as unfortunately occurs sometimes in law
there are loopholes
and a loophole was discovered and
exploited by
the town of Hooksett a couple years ago
and now by the town of Londonderry
so what that loophole is
is
a community would take a group two
position
in this case in both cases a fire
Chief's position
and in essence decertify it to a
part-time position
but yet bring on board a person to
fulfill the role of the fire chief
in the case of Hooksett or in the case
of Londonderry retire their Fire Chief
and bring him right back
now what that does in essence is it has
two effects one it creates double
dipping which
this body has
expressly
stated
that they're not in favor of
the other thing that it did
or it does is when you decertify a
position and you put it to part-time all
of a sudden the debt that you that that
position has created as far as the
unfunded liability goes
disappears
now of course the debt itself doesn't
disappear the debt is very much still
there but the responsibility of that
Community as part of their payment of
said debt
now for some reason goes away
so that debt is now transferred to other
communities because we have to pay the
debt so
if your community finds a way out of
paying the debt then someone else's
Community is going to have to take that
on
and that's really not fair that's not
fair to the system it's not fair to
other communities
and it
this is one of those cases whereas you
know for those of us that are stewards
of this system
on the legislative side this is
something that damages things
and when we uncover things that do that
it is in our best interest to to deal
with them so this was discussed two
years ago
okay at the time we had
a modern example and one from the 90s
and it has become a
glowingly obvious that we need to really
nip this in the bud
so the language that's the background
the language basically says that if a
political subdivision employer
eliminates a group two position
or transfers that position to a
part-time position with
that the retirement system needs to
conduct an analysis of the debt of that
position and that Community still needs
to pay their debt
now how does one do that
right because salaries change over time
you could have an anomaly in a given
year you could even have a community say
you know what we're just gonna
we're going to pay you this for a year
and then bring you in part time so this
is why there's a five-year look back
this provides a a relative standard it's
it it evens out maybe
Ebbs and flows of salary and it provides
a number for which the retirement system
can base their analysis on
now in the interest of of discouraging
this type of activity
it comes with a 20 penalty
because it's not just a matter of not
paying the unfunded portion
but the the retirement system requires
income from folks in those positions
that come out of their paychecks 80
roughly round numbers 80 percent of the
benefits that are paid out in a given
year come right out of the paychecks of
the current employees
so to prevent those three occurrences
from causing harm to the system the 20
penalty is in there to discourage this
activity we're not we can't prohibit it
we cannot tell a town
that they're going to eliminate a
position
that would start to fly in the face of
28a
but what we're going to say is if you do
eliminate that position the debt that
you have incurred on that position you
are still responsible for
that is the gist
of house bill 461.
uh represent Pearson I have a question
sure why are you limiting this to group
two I know that the Pittsfield school
system did something similar they
retired their superintendent and brought
them back part-time
um good question and I know that the
counties
in
have been saying well we'll save money
by not having to make retirement
contributions if we bring in a retired
person to do this job
so to answer your question Madam chair
the reasoning was simply because we saw
examples of this in the group 2 world
and I was not aware of
examples in the group one world I am
certainly not opposed
to this applying to both if there are if
we do have a problem in group one as
well
okay thank you so it was an inadvertent
omission and not a conscious decision
absolutely correct does anyone else have
any questions
yes thank you representative leckis
uh thank you
um
so I initially I was I was uh kind of
concerned about the 20 penalty and
wasn't necessarily happy with it but I
have a question
normally if you have a a regular
full-time person in there then over time
their salary tends to go up both as
they're in the position longer and
compensate for inflation whatever but
with this five-year look back that's
going to be a fixed number right it's
it's not going to be increased yeah the
idea of a five-year look back would be
to look at whatever the highest salary
that was give that was offered during
that five-year period that just prevents
that's trying to prevent a loophole in
essence of of planning this event
when you decide you're going to go this
route with someone you really like who
wants to retire but yet keep doing the
same job follow up follow up thank you
um
right but the there's still some Ben I'm
asking you it looks like and tell me if
I'm right that there's still some
benefit to the employer
because and it may be small but because
they're that number is fixed whereas a
salary for an actual employee is
probably going to ride they would still
be paying less
um towards the uaal as well as pension
benefits thank you for explaining why I
put the 20 penalty in there thank you
other other questions yes representative
Bailey
thank you madam chair
um
is is it always the same I've heard at
candidates nights and things that uh
the fire an elective fire chief is not
necessarily in group two correct because
they're not full-time so then if
so if you started with a uh follow-up
again thank you if you followed up
if uh
if one fire chief was an actual Fire
Chief and was certified in the whole
thing
and it was not re-elected in favor of
somebody who was not certified and not a
fire chief
how would all this work it would be
irrelevant I am not aware of a single
elected fire chief in the state of New
Hampshire that qualifies as a full-time
group to
employee those those positions are are
appointed by the by you know they're
hired as a regular employee by towns and
cities thank you okay
I have an additional what else
uh isn't looking back to 2020 uh
retroactive and their boy
unconstitutional
yeah
fine so we
yep yes it is madam chair
um
that was uh that was done as an
attention getter
fine so we will if we decide to pass
anything of this bill we will have to
make sure that it's from the effective
date of this legislation and it didn't
work by the way the the specific town
that that is currently involved in this
did not uh is not here and did not reach
out to me
representative true and then Schmidt
thank you madam chair
so
is this bill saying that
a town ought not to
reduce
their fire or police force
what it is saying is that if you choose
to do so you still have to pay the debt
on the positions to which you created
the debt
so it a police department could could
eliminate half its positions
we're not telling a community a city or
town to what size they should have
anything but what we're saying is that
if for you had a police department of 20
and you choose to go down to 10 you
still have 10 positions of debt that you
are responsible for
that we are that you cannot transfer to
a different community
that that is what that says thank you
personally better than like us
thank you madam chair representative
Pearson could you explain why that
situation that representative true just
asked about would be detrimental to the
retirement system well simply enough if
to use round numbers let's say that that
the retirement system figures out that
each one of those positions encompasses
a hundred thousand dollars of debt
if you were to eliminate five positions
that's half a million dollars well that
half a million dollars is still debt
it's still part of the unfunded
liability calc you know calculation so
that half a million dollars now has to
be paid instead of being paid by Sandown
it's now paid by Dairy and epsom and
Hudson
so what we do not want to get into here
is a is a the use of a loophole to
transfer a community's debt onto another
community
and this would prevent that from
happening
okay thank you representative
thank you madam chair representative
Pearson I was just curious what the
compelling uh part of this was like did
it come to your attention did you get a
phone call did you were you did you
become aware of it and then started
looking into it it was like oh that's
one town that's two towns so
the
the first the first instance of this I
became aware of simply because I knew
the person who was involved
um who is a great guy this is nothing
against I won't even name him it's not
against him personally
and
um and that seemed like kind of a
one-off event until
what the town of Hooksett did
um for whatever reason they chose to do
that that's a that's up to them but
that was not I don't believe in any way
that that was the town of hooksett's
intent
at all
it was to
um was to either transfer dead or get
out of paying
that part of it I
I'm not gonna
I'm not going to say that that was was
their intent at all
um the current intent is a little bit
more clear
with that because they brought the same
person back so that really involves two
things that we typically don't like to
see which is double dipping and debt
transfer
so that's it's one of those things where
I think that if we don't if we don't
quench this flame pun intended here now
this has the potential to become a a
bigger problem later and as
chairman McGuire so elegantly pointed
out once they do it I can't go backwards
and undo it
so we have we've got to stop this now
before this becomes
practice absolutely thank you
representative thank you um
so
let's see if I'm correct you're saying
it's it's not just a situation this
won't just apply
if you turn a full-time position into a
part-time position if you eliminate the
position altogether either way either
way okay follow up follow up so
if you have expanded a department and
you've done it for a few years you
decide you don't need it you cut it back
down
then you're the town or the employer
will be on the hook as if that had been
an employee and they'd accumulated this
debt over a long period of time when
really that's not true that so
that
procedure process and Analysis is is not
addressed here because the retirement
system will calculate that that the
process of that will be on them to
determine and that's complicated
um okay so it's they're not just going
to continue paying the same UI you know
the payment towards ual as if it was
still a an employee it would be uh some
different amount it would take into
account things like how long the
position has been there that's why
that's why it says
um analysis for the retirement system as
to the unfunded liability for that
position okay thank you
thank you madam chair
so uh you may recall I believe you're on
the committee at the time we had a bill
a couple years ago that would have you
know removed a certain Community I think
from the retirement system and this
whole subject came up at that time that
in in so doing you're you're walking
away from all your commitments
in an attempt to you know to reduce the
cost of your talent employees but
um the the bottom line is that this this
is we we have this idea when we
give an employee or employee group a
cola
has to be terminally funded that's why
it's so much more expensive than just a
single uh you know say an extra 13th
month check
um and so forth so this is it do you
think that there that the town is very
often doing it ignorantly of the
ramifications for the system
it would be difficult like I said before
I don't I don't really know what the the
overall intent was I'm not gonna I know
you're not ascribing that I'm not
ascribing that at all and I but but yes
I you know I think communities focus on
what's going on in front of them and not
necessarily the state you know the the
health and wellness of the state pension
system that's pretty much our job
thank you
representative Gerhart thank you madam
chair
to be
I'm thinking about demographic Trends
just people move out of different areas
Go in different areas as far as schools
closing if we were to apply this across
the board what would happen then
well it would depend on what they do
with their staff because you know
there's but again even even in the I'll
give a great example the town of dairy
we've had a reduction in student in our
student population since 1996.
we are substantially lower than we were
back then
but
and we're not this wouldn't apply to
folks back then because this is going to
take effect whenever it's passed 60 days
after passage if it if it goes through
over the over the time period where
these positions exist
there was debt that a pension debt that
occurred so
it's not fair for my town to or my
school district to walk away excuse me
from that debt
simply because they just you know we had
a lower student enrollment population
and we kind of scaled things down
because the debts never really walked
away from it's just transferred to some
other community
so
that is exactly a circumstance that
would be legitimate in this case that
that's the part of the point of this but
we're not gonna we're not telling a
school district that can't reduce their
staff we're just saying that the debt
that they occurred over that time period
is their responsibility
except that every school department in
the state is facing a reduced student
population
so that may be a very difficult thing to
implement representative Simon yeah that
might hit towards my question as I'm
just thinking through the ramifications
of this so the implication would be that
the more employees that there are the
less each employee's portion of the
unfunded liability is correct so you're
trying to keep people from reducing the
number of employees they have no not at
all okay there's nothing in here that
that prohibits or prevents or says you
know don't do don't reduce your
employees you absolutely can but just
keep in mind you have responsibilities
for the employee that you had follow up
sorry
um clarifying
that came across the wrong way I guess
what I'm saying is the more employees in
the system the more diluted the
responsibility to the uaal is for each
individual person
we have a hundred thousand people as
opposed to 200 000 people is the
responsibility for each individual
person as far as the uaal is concerned
less if there are two hundred thousand I
suppose I don't I don't think so I don't
think it is because the you know each
individual employee
um has their foreign
actually the the story is that the uaal
was incurred
from the 90s to about 07 and it's a
fixed amount and it just a current
employee should not be incurring any
additional uaal
sure if you were to hire someone today
right that they're being fully paid for
so if you in essence if you created a
position in 20
20 in eliminated in 2025 the the effect
of this would probably be zero
so follow up
so in essence then when the nhrs is
going back to determine whether or not a
position is
um
incurring liability and would need to
pay this they're looking back toward to
what that town had for employees at the
time that the uaal was first instituted
good question
and that's a process that would be a
a process question for them because like
I said the the rules to which this will
be implemented under would be set by the
retirement system the intent here I
think is pretty clear so it's it's just
their application of that
so that's a question from Marty Ethan it
would very much be a question for Marty
yeah
it's it is
from representative Pearson thank you
very much thank you madam chair Mr
Carlin you've had a uh a warning of the
questions
uh thank you again Madam chair for the
record Marty Carlin representing the New
Hampshire retirement system uh the
retirement system has no position on
this bill
um I can I can speak in general terms
about how we read the provision
um you know in that day that'll answer
some of the questions uh people had but
you know addressing the bill as drafted
it speaks to group two positions so
essentially and it's it if it passed it
would sort of lock in the number of
group two positions for all Employers in
the state they can add to that number
but if it goes below
you know this or positions are
eliminated you know there would be the
the assessment penalty would would kick
in
um you know
um representative Simon was talking
about individual liabilities for you
know for particular employers and things
like that and our employer rates are
calculated to spread you know the
liability you know that's the same rate
you know whether you're in in you know
little Tanner Amherst or you know
Portsmouth you know the police and fire
rates are the same you know and it's
it's it's assessed as a percentage of
the payroll so you know the higher
salary you know the more contributions
come in
the bill right on its face you know just
says you know it we would get salary
information for that position for the
previous five years whatever
um you know five you know whatever that
the highest one is we would assess the
current employer rate plus 20 percent
um so right now the group two uh
employer rates are about 31 percent
foreign
so so if you know just just for the sake
of round numbers and I don't think you
know these are probably higher but it's
just easier to conceptualize okay
there's a uh you have eliminated a group
two position and you're hiring somebody
on a part-time basis for a hundred
thousand dollars So based on the current
you know employer rates I'll just say 30
percent presume it's it's fire so 20
penalty is 36 percent of pay so you'd be
paying you know thirty six thousand
dollars a year going forward that was
based on the highest salary in the
previous five years while the person was
uh well the position was a contributing
position to the retirement system so it
you know if if if we're looking for
individual liabilities for specific
people it gets a lot more complicated
we'd have to have the actual redo those
at a cost on on a per person basis we
read this is It's a flat
you know formula for everybody
um you know so you know our just just
from a process
um concern it says you know the employer
shall not eliminate or transfer or
position to part-time without an
analysis from nhrs but it doesn't spell
out you know
usually with things like that there's
language about you know on a form
determined you know by the Board of
Trustees or something like that so you
know you know and you know that if an
employer doesn't do that exercise and
eliminates a position and nobody notices
it you know we're not gonna
find out about it until you know we do
an audit you know you know somewhere in
the next you know three to seven years
with the employer so so there's just
some some process pieces I mean if it's
as simple as we create a form you know
employer downloads it puts the name of
the position if they have a number
associated with it which we wouldn't
have any way to verify they put in the
salary information and we just you know
find the find the biggest number
multiply it by the current percent plus
20 and say you need to pay us this
amount you know in perpetuity you know
it wouldn't be part of the monthly
reporting uh for you know members and
employers that come in because nobody's
accruing a benefit for that essentially
any of the
money coming in for from the elimination
of these positions would be treated as
an Actuarial gain so it would all go
towards the unfunded liability
you know so to the extent if it's a
couple of million dollars you know and
you know over the over the course of a
year that's just coming straight off the
ual so the next time the rates are
certified they'd be that small but lower
so I hope that you know and then there's
there's we don't see anything in here
where the retirement system would be
making any determination on whether it
was right or wrong oh you know the
population dropped and they got rid of
somebody I mean it's pretty
straightforward you eliminate a position
or you convert it to part-time there's a
fee so there's no
you know way to adjudicate you know
what what the reasons they did for it it
assumes you know that you know you're
just paying the liability regardless and
honestly if there was some sort of uh
set up to look at those I we I don't
know if we'd be comfortable making
determinations on the merits of you know
whether you know Beau should have 27
police or 26 you know what I mean it's
kind of outside our they agree to make
those determinations and you don't have
to pay the penalty and you do away you
know right now it's a blanket penalty
okay in perpetuity yes representative
Dolan and then Marcus and paper
uh thank you madam chair uh question for
you it uh we hear a lot
that school enrollments are dropping
everywhere
which would seem to suggest we're over
staffed with teachers
uh we also hear a lot that we can't hire
enough First Responders firefighters
where many communities of 20 30 below
what their open positions are so we're
short-handed in that regard
so my question is is this bill
going to help mitigate some of those
uh levels of Staffing that whether
they're too high in the terms of
teachers are too low in terms of First
Responders always neutral I I I'm not
even I'm not sure if you know we could
and now you know you know even analyze
that you know that that question I mean
it does
you know it to the extent that the
penalty
changes Behavior regarding head count it
could have some impact but I couldn't
say whether you know what what that
impact would be you know because if you
know when the employer is doing the
calculus of how much am I paying the
full-time or plus retirement how much of
them paying the part-timer plus the
penalty you know it and look at the
numbers their decision making may be
influenced by that so
uh so so when I'm wrestling with is does
this change
help
or hurt us with regard to the various
payrolls that are out there and
or is that is that not the intent that
that it would help or hurt and or you
just want no position well I I think um
you know you know representative Pearson
referred to this and as a general
principle you know the you know the the
actuary predicts you know the head count
to be relatively stable you know you
know for for the member groups we don't
expect you know people keep we keep
hiring new public employees or that you
know there's going to be a you know Mass
Exodus of you know you know five
thousand fewer and five years than there
are now
um but um so to the extent that the
unfunded liability is assessed on the
total payroll of all contributing
members if there are fewer contributing
members you know that
liability is the same amount but it's
it's assessed at a higher rate on the
remaining employers so sort of
collectively if you know you know the
you know there was a community that
went away from full-time employees
entirely you know their liabilities
didn't wouldn't go away but they all the
other employers will be paying a
fraction of them because they don't have
any covered payroll on which to assess
it so you know it it's kind of a
complicated answer I hope it helped
but yes and I and many of employers in
the state have noticed that they're
paying a lot to the retirement system
for their employees and they are making
decisions based on
how they can not do so
so they hire part-time people or
whatever
representative leckis thank you um so
representative Pearson gave an example
saying that if someone were a position
were open in 2020 and then they decided
they didn't need any more and close it
in 2025 that his assumption how the
retirement system would handle it would
be that because they weren't employed
during the time the uaal was you know
about the
what's going with you the problem was
going on that
um this would result in them
in the town and the employer not paying
anything from what you said recently
though it seems to me that that's not
the case
so with which is a
because if you know if if you know the
town's payroll was three million dollars
and they eliminated position so the
payroll was only you know two million
dollars you know this you know they
would be paying the employer rate you
know as as calculated but they'd be
paying it on a smaller payroll base so
that
additional contributions you know would
be
essentially sort of spread out among all
the participating employers so you know
and and you know if you're talking you
know one position two positions I mean
it's in the rounding you know in terms
of how much more each you know
individual employer is going to pay but
it does you know
you know spread that out among everyone
you know
follow-up
yeah that's not really
maybe it's answering an indirect way but
I'm concerned about the particular case
where an employee was hired not during
the period that the wrong you know an
inadequate amount of money must be put
in
and then the positions eliminated so
that the employer has not accrued in my
view any debt whatsoever and they
shouldn't have to be paying any of this
so when I heard that from represent
Pearson it made me feel a lot better
about this bill but from what you're
saying that's not the case they're still
going to
um
you know they'll still have to pay based
on the you know the highest the last
five years for that employee even even
if the position didn't exist during the
earlier period is that correct
yes in the sense that the employer rates
are the same for all members regardless
of when they entered the system so the
person who's been here 25 years and
perhaps in their first half of their
career because of
related issues there was an unfunded
liability Associated we weren't
collecting the contributions correctly
you know in somebody who started last
month still 30 percent of pay for both
of them
one last follow-up if I could one last
follow-up so to have it work the way
representative Pearson said
um I mean could you suggest any language
you don't have to answer right now but
that would actually make that happen
thank you
it would be extremely complicated to
calculate that based on the service of
the individuals in the position and if
if it was somebody switched positions in
mid course and it gets even and more
complicated uh you know so I'm not sure
if there's a solution to that to your
concern
okay representative
thank you madam chair Marty would you
mind
drafting up a cheat sheet for me just
like you did
with 436
just sort of a hypothetical here's at
this employer rate you know this is what
it would cost the town that's an easy
one yeah
okay easier than 4 30. well if you're
not executing it today I can do it if uh
this will be going to the pension
subcommittee thank you because it's
clearly more complicated than it looked
at first reading
uh are there any other questions from Mr
Carl representative Simon uh thank you
madam chair yeah so the representative
Lake assist questions we're getting back
to the one that I had initially asked
obviously without the uaal rates are
just equal across the board and people
pay in and you run the actuary on it but
the uaal is getting spread out among all
present employees so as the employee
pool drops the share for each
contributing member goes up which is the
concern right
so technically
as the pool goes down the liability for
the next person to get get out goes up
the expense to that person would be more
expensive than the person who got out
previously my concern with this is that
it is like there's an incentive to get
out sooner because the later you get out
so if you're at a school system for
example and you're looking to
um
you're looking to downsize because your
student population is going down and you
need to lay off teachers and your
liability according to this bill is
going to get go up the more other
schools beat you to the punch you may
want to get out sooner rather than later
potentially it's just
would that would that be accurate
you know it um
when you talk about you know getting
beat to the punch I mean the the this uh
penalty as it's structured you know the
the employer would still be paying money
to nhrs it wouldn't be I don't think it
would be technically considered employer
contributions anymore because it's not
going to board's funding benefits for
anyone it's it's additional money over
and above you know what's coming in from
Member and employee contributions
already so to that extent you know the
two years later when we set the new
rates whatever
whatever Revenue was generated through
these penalties that would just come off
the uaal you know shave off you know a
point or something so it would it would
um
it it has the potential to lower the ual
rate for all the participating member
employers and members paying in because
because you're getting money that you
weren't anticipating sooner you know so
so um you know but it's it's you know
don't think of it you know I mean it's I
don't know it's more complicated yeah no
it's more of a balancing act part of
it's going to drop part of it's going to
go up what outpaces what yeah so so the
incentives you know you know as I
mentioned earlier is you know is it
worth it to eliminate this position or
turn it to part-time because we're going
to end up paying just as much you know
that way and that's that's a you know a
local decision and there's really no
right or wrong answer it depends on the
circumstances the facts of the
particular position thank you for the
clarification appreciate it any other
questions represent true
thank you madam chair
good morning
um so in the in the position of in the
situation where a fire chief
is a decertified or he's old enough so
he just retires
and they don't refill that position they
bring him back or somebody back
uh uh is part-time is does that create a
debt
what was the position that the retiree
is filling was it ever a contributing
position to the retirement system was
there a prior full-timer so he he was a
full-time fire chief at 25 years he
retires yeah they don't hire another
full-time
they bring him or someone back
time well if the guy retired but he was
eligible for retirement is there a
continuing debt even though he's retired
it you know collectively you know you
know it we don't calculate to the
individual level but collectively
there's an unfunded liability so the
contributions coming in on that position
when it was full-time aren't coming in
anymore so that's that's the difference
that that's that's the the part that
gets spread out among everyone else
thank you yes okay anyone else
thank you very much is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill 461
all right seeing none the it will be
sent to this pension subcommittee
and we are done for the morning we're
resuming at one o'clock in executive
side
okay we have I'm starting the executive
session on
House Bill 258 and House Bill 436
House Bill tooth
436 right
okay House Bill 258 as I understand that
we're not ready to vote on uh we're not
and I'm still waiting for the notice but
okay we should have a subcommittee
meeting on Friday
on that one
uh in that case I'm going to
going to assess that one to the planned
executive session on March 8th
which has not yet but does not get in
the calendar but it's it will be planned
and for committee uh reference
I'm not going to be scheduling anything
for the next two weeks except
subcommittees
are free to meet that's
there will be no no committee meetings
rejoicing
well you know some of you might have a
life that you'd like to uh
do something with it at that time
okay
all right so
um
I'll spill
436 went to the pension committee
representative Simon
thank you madam chair the um
the subcommittee uh has agreed and so I
am putting forward
amendments 2023-0483h
for consideration for the committee
is there a second
second
okay
Simon and Schmidt do you wish I presume
you wish to speak to your mind yeah
probably a good idea
um so the amendment uh completely
overhauls the original bill it deals
with members of uh group two of the New
Hampshire retirement system that had
begun service but had not yet been
vested by 2011 when the calculation of
benefits um
changed in statute
[Music]
um
the amendment does a few things
the first thing that it does if you're
looking on page one of the amendment
it's quite a long Amendment but first
first page line five through seven
um it does two things in this area the
first thing it does is it it defines the
word vested to mean a member has
qualified benefit upon 10 years of
service this has always been the assumed
condition in New Hampshire the New
Hampshire retirement system does all of
its actualizing based off of that idea
but it was never in statute so we're
simply putting it in statute so it's on
the books the second part of it states
that calculations for earnable
compensation so what Avenues of Revenue
an employee can make goes towards their
final compensation and also the average
final compensation itself on which their
benefits are determined cannot be
reduced after three years of service so
once a member of group two has put in
three years of service those two
components with no longer be allowed to
be adjusted
doesn't that apply to every every person
not just group two
that is correct no you are correct it
applies to both group one and one name
yes it does apply to a group on a group
two thank you for that clarification
clarification
um so that's the two changes there
um if you change if you move on to page
eight
of the amendments
um lines
through 25
it also changes
um the provision that the final benefit
would be calculated on 85 percent of the
members average final compensation
changes it to a hundred percent and it
also increases
um the cap for the compensation which
was at 120 000 to 125 000 with an annual
increase of 1.25 percent
um each year thereafter that is a
basically been put in there to account
for a small amount of inflation so that
the cap doesn't stagnate in its amount
um yes
are those the Amendments yes those are
the copies of the amendment just not
every everybody doesn't have them
okay if anybody needs one
does anybody need a copy of the
amendment
it's slightly older but it's close
enough there's no major structural
changes to it
again
all right the next thing that the bill
does
um is it adjusts the calculation table
for members who had begun service but
had not yet been vested by 2011 there is
a chart on page seven I believe
that outlines
um the change in the
contribution calculations are
not the contribution calculations but
the actual
um
final
I don't know the word's gone
um they're fine yes it's how they
calculate their final benefit
um and the bill will take on a year by
year basis each line
um
of years of service at the time of this
change and it will repeal one year at a
time
um placing the members in that group
from the new contribution system to the
old contribution system and essentially
put them back in the contribution system
that was in place when they were hired
originally the bill amends itself nine
times each year a new group is a new
line of this chart is repealed and a new
group is moved back into the previous
benefits that they were offered when
they were first hired or at least were
on the books when they were first hired
the last thing that it does is
it terminally funds it through the
general fund of the of the
General Court
this is on page 11 line 28
the amendment allocates 25 million per
year for a 10-year period to terminally
fund our estimates for this are already
lower than that
um and and they come in significantly
lower
um than the than the 250 if this is left
as is any money that isn't used to fund
this
would then be sent down to the
municipalities to reduce their rates
that was what that's how Marty explained
to me well what if there is any if all
of the money given to the retirement
system is not needed to fund this
benefit it will be used to reduce the
uaal which will affect the calculations
that the employers pay okay is that
correct okay I'm sorry I misunderstood
that from the last subcommittee meeting
um of course this is also going to
finance so Finance
can amend it to more accurately reflect
the actual
estimate that comes out of the New
Hampshire retirement system and that
would come back to the floor so that we
don't have quite a as large a gap
between what we're estimating and what
we will actually be spending in a
nutshell that's the major changes
to the ball
I'd like to add that the rest of the
bill is implementing those changes so
it's a lot you can't just say
in a one line it for example page on
page one what it does is it breaks apart
burnable compensation for group one
which is unchanged from current statute
and earnable conversation for group two
which is slightly more fun
representative Schmidt do you wish to
speak to your motion or your second
I do Madam chair thank you very much I
want to begin and this is not an uh no
an attempt to win the chairs vote but to
to speak uh the truth as I see it uh
that uh chairman Maguire uh it has a a
truly formidable understanding of the
situation as a result of years of
involvement with the retirement system
both as the chair of the committee but
also as a member of the decennial
commission where she was involved with
the subject as well and so her
understanding of the of the situation is
uh is a big asset in terms of making
sure that we do the best job that we can
under the circumstances and I also want
to salute the subcommittee chair who
also conducted a very effective review
of the situation uh with a lot of
involvement of uh
representative Stephen Pearson who
understands the situation very well
um and having sat in 301 303 about uh 10
years ago it seems like uh with a room
full of of
First Responders who were very
grim-faced at the prospect of what the
retirement system was going to do to
them in under the pressure of
circumstances and I think a number of
things were done that that
were not fair
and this amendment I believe
restores a number of of situations to a
much fairer and better situation
so I am going to enthusiastically not
only second motion ought to pass but
also to vote high on measure when it
comes to my term
lack of
thank you um so I noticed this as I
understand at least just deals with
group two I'm wondering if I mean I
don't know all the details what happened
when the changes occurred
um does this whole issue not not apply
at all to group one it does not apply to
group one because
wait the only two classes were created
group two was sliced into different
categories and set for the transition
and the difference between the older and
the newer employees was more
um
was larger and plus there's more steps
in between and that was one of the the
issues that this bill is intended to uh
um to solve and just to follow up on
that in the for group one you said there
were two categories so we passed the
time where that's relevant or no no
no and it
okay there
not attain vested
it's
just wondering if we're going to be
faced with coming back and dealing with
that aspect there hasn't been as much of
a concern on the part of group one
so far
yes representative shua thank you madam
chair I'll just add that um
a concern group two more because
they they only had to serve a more
limited number of years in order to be
retired who knows group one obviously
had to
in order to qualify for a good benefit
normally would work probably 30 years or
more so it wasn't as concerning when it
got changed for some of those folks
foreign
true
uh thank you madam chip
um
I voted for this in subcommittee because
the amendment in my view is certainly a
lot better than the original bill
the original Bill involved downshifting
to the towns
and as it's been said this is terminally
funded
the the state
is going to is going to pick up this
cost
my problem is
with the cost
um
200 to 250 we don't we don't really know
uh
where the what the cost will be but it
is substantial
and I will quote from uh what I speak to
as the truth
article 10 New Hampshire Constitution
government being instituted for the
common benefit protection and security
of the whole community
and not for the private interest
interest or emoluments above any one-man
family
or class of men
I realized there was a a
strong desire to
to correct what the
pension reforms of 2011.
this amendment addresses
1731 people
math is not my strong point
but looking at the community of New
Hampshire the people of New Hampshire
that's 1731
represents zero point
zero zero
one percent
one thousand one one thousandth
of one percent
of the people in New Hampshire
is where this 200 to 250 million dollars
is going
and because of article 10 I can't
support
the bill is amended
thank you madam chair
yes I did some calculations and it's
something
over a hundred thousand dollars per
person involved
we don't know exactly how much but it's
it's going in that range
and the
the only reason that I'm supporting it
is that we are currently paying
substantial sums
to retain our police and fire and also
to recruit new ones
if this is a way which of course comes
out of your taxes
primarily your local taxes because
nearly all police and fire are local
employees not state employees
so
if we're thinking of this as a
a change the retirement system to help
solve our Recruitment and Retention
issues
and we hope that it will do so and
thereby save the towns a great deal of
money
in the future so they won't have to pay
hiring bonuses they won't have to deal
with
rapid turnover
where they won't have to pay people
bonuses to stick stick around for
another year or two
um
it's a question everybody has to ask
themselves is it worth it
you know the the num the data's there we
do know we have a recruitment and
retention problem
and the question is is this enough to
solve it or at least make a big stab at
solving it
so I hope you will all consider that
representative Simon thank you madam
chair and this might be I mean it is a
bit of a controversy
um but also according to the
Constitution we're not allowed to make
retroactive law and and I do think that
comes into play here
um the terms that were changed were not
contractual changes they were changes
that were made to statute so unlike
other pensions
um
the nhrs
their their benefits or their their
terms are are actually written into law
their their New Hampshire law and so
there is an argument to be made that
when we went back and had to make
changes in 2011 when we made the changes
to the benefit program we were making
them in statute and therefore making
retroactive statute that was injurious
to people it changed the rate of their
compensation in a sense through their
retirement benefits
um so yes this isn't
from that perspective a new benefit it's
simply a check that was written a while
ago that really hasn't been cached and
now it's kind of time to pay it can also
be looked up from that perspective so
just offer that
representative
thank you madam chair
I wanted to
reiterate what representative Simon just
stated about retroactive changes and the
fact of the matter is these benefits
were given as a term of employment and
then taken away and I I think this is
our opportunity to right the wrong uh
also to representative
McGuire's comments regarding retention I
have heard
directly from
corrections officer who oversees the
correction officers out of wolfborough
wolfborough that they will in fact stay
if we can get this in place
so that those are my comments thank you
okay
any other comments questions
all right in that case the motion is to
adopt amendment
0483h to House Bill 436
and the clerk can call the roll one
ready Madam chair yes if I may request
since our
erstwhile Democratic leader is not
present if the clerk could call
Representative Schmidt first we would
appreciate that sure
no her name yeah she since
representative groda is not here to me
she's normally the first
fine with me okay
representative Schmidt no no no no
right okay you're trying to kick now
just to confuse me purely uh
do I still get to call uh to respond
when my name is called
representative shewitt
not only the Republicans go first
okay
so here and then start jumping around
representative Davis is in his first day
as a substitute Clerk and and we should
be nice to him for taking on the for
taking on that thankless job it
[Laughter]
I'm waiting for the bonus representative
true awkwardness
representative Simon yes
representative lakis yes
representative Bailey
yes
representative Santo nazasto
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
representative short
what do you want Schmidt first
okay
representative Schmidt
aye
representative goalie
yes
representative shuitt yes
representative tolerski
yes representative massimoa yeah
clerk votes yes representative Wilhelm
yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith
that's representative Schultz's film
sorry for representative Smith yes
and uh the chair yes
19 years zero Nays all right the mo the
amendment is adopted representative
Simon
thank you madam chair I would like to
move otpa on HB 436. second okay do you
wish to speak to your emotion
uh no I think I've said everything
during the amendment speech
representative Schmidt
I want to applaud the committee for its
unanimous vote this is important that we
show the house that that we are behind
this this fix in the last hour so thank
you okay
anyone else wish to comment questions on
the bill is amended
okay thank you very much in that case
the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 436 and the
clerking call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey no
representative sent on disasto no
representative true no
representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard
yes
um
representative Schmidt
aye
representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes
representative delarski yes
representative massamila yes
representative Wilhelm yes
Clark vote Yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
and representative Schmidt
sorry yes
amateur yeah yes
16 years three Nays okay the motion
passes 16-3 it will be on the regular
calendar due to the cost impact
and does anyone wish to write a Minority
Report
okay representative Santo nastasso will
write a Minority Report
which is due today
all right
okay that's that bill that's the last
for our executive session
and we will we have a public hearing at
two o'clock
so thank you all for being here
you're doing this committee last chance
right
um
who made the first motion
Simon okay I should have known that
right
then the final one is ought to pass as
amended sorry to confuse the different
holy spirit
it's tough when you're feeling it
there's somebody who's better well I
wasn't I didn't realize
my party first well the
yeah
and then that's so that anyone who is
wavering or passing me to understand
or independent people but it gets
confusing people say oh yeah well
representative Corona voters
to an executive session on March 8th
which will be
um
notice sometimes okay do you want the
board with meeting today
I want you to get that that important
information to the head of the
suspicability family representative
Corrections
they're still considering that they
wanted the information
I'm gonna go make sure the paper works
all right to speak for her she wanted it
right off
um
yeah
foreign
where are you yeah
um
adults
foreign
thank you
check out
my business so
um
you want to say that
okay
thank you okay
thank you
very much
it may not work
foreign
where do they put it
in here
sticking to your guns I'll call First
over my damn well feeling at home that's
what I'm talking about
[Laughter]
thanks for putting up with me guys I
appreciate it
I I it's hard for me to say no
welcome back
the uh
work
there's at least two items being handed
out one is the amendment to House Bill
and the other is the testimony by
representative
there may be more coming
all right I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 559 and I call Representative
agoyer
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan McGuire I represent the town of
epson
and um the the bill I'm going to talk to
you about today is House Bill 559 we got
it fairly late in the drafting process
and so I asked for an amendment which I
got back just last night and we already
found an error or two so I handed it out
it's not that different in structure or
content from from the original bill but
I'm going to leave it to representative
uh like us to to talk about that in the
details I'm going to talk about the big
Concepts and the and the important
aspects of this bill
and Madam chair with your permission I
mean I'm gonna unfortunately have to
speak for longer than three minutes and
so I I'm going to if it's all right so
listen to questions as I go at that
appropriate break points as opposed to
you know talking for 20 minutes and then
and then stopping right so committee if
you uh have an urgent question or when
he pauses we will take questions then
all right so this bill would is a is a
very small step to introduce a defined
contribution pension plan to Prime
contribution retirement plan
to public employees in the state of New
Hampshire
it it carves out a very tiny set of
those employees new
state
group one employees so not anyone who is
currently
an employee people who would start after
July on July 1st 2024 or later
people who work for the state and people
who would be part of group one otherwise
just for Simplicity we call this group
three so so it's easier to talk about
um the current defined benefit plan the
current Retirement System
is Antiquated in my view it was designed
for a long time ago for situation that
that doesn't
maintain today
and that's why if you look at the the
private sector you'll see that almost
all such plans have disappeared
right in the private sector people both
employers and employees have strong
incentives to do what each other likes
right I mean it's hard to find employees
so they have to be satisfied and and
what what we see in the private sector
is Define contribution plans
so let's talk about the weaknesses of a
defined benefit plan
so first of all it's a fixed income plan
the amount of income that you get is
when you retire
it comes to you according to a formula
and I put the formula there it's the
number of years of service times the
average of your top five earning years
divided by 66. assuming you're 65 and
older and there's some changes for
different areas but that's it basically
it the main problem with a fixed income
is what you've all seen with requests
for colas fixed income doesn't work when
there's inflation
a defined contribution plan on the other
hand is not a fixed income right you
have at least some chance that it will
increase your income with inflation
because you own things you own stocks
and businesses and real estate and stuff
like that for your retirement and so
it's not a formula it's it's uh um it's
an actual investment okay
secondly it's a defined benefit plan is
is not portable
and in this group of employees that
we're talking about there's a large
number of employees that don't last till
vesting so the current defined benefit
plan has 10-year vesting
so I ask you to turn to
um oh let's turn to page two
so you see the chart that's that's
inflation right so so
um these are 20-year periods starting in
night ending in 1948 through the present
so you can see in certain periods we've
had up to 250 percent inflation and in
the minimum it's something like 75 50 to
75 percent inflation right so so I think
we're on the upslope and we can talk
about why at maybe via question but but
I think we're getting heading back to
one of those High inflation periods okay
now look at this toward the bottom where
it says number of jobs held in a
lifetime
so this is statistics from the Bureau of
Labor Statistics they say that the
average person that they studied in this
group eight people who were born between
1957 and 1964 is that they had 12.4 jobs
in their lifetime
all right so on average they're staying
at a job three three and a half years
they have lots of different jobs so the
fraction that will be there for 10-year
vesting in this group is very small and
and in fact if you look at the very the
paragraph at the bottom these are the
numbers assumed by the New Hampshire
retirement system for how many people
are going to quit every year or get
terminated maybe they get fired who
knows but they leave the system every
year so people with up to one year of
service 27 so people in their first year
of hire 27 percent gone of the remaining
people second year 21
third year 15
fourth year 12 then 10 so all together
that's 61 of the people who start so
after five years you only have 39 of the
people you started with left and they
still have five years for to vest right
so the fraction of people that you're
helping with the system is low right um
why we we have trouble hiring and we
have trouble keeping people is the
system doesn't work for them it doesn't
work for people that are normal that
that move around on jobs right so so it
if you go afterwards after the 10 they
they assume roughly seven percent per
year so what that works out to what that
pencils out to is only 27 percent of the
original people that were hired make it
to vesting right 73 don't
all right so the system to the extent
that it works and helps people who are
vested
is helping a very small fraction of the
of the total employees so so it's it
this is an issue it doesn't comport with
the actual experience of employees now I
personally think okay just a moment
Peter I I I personally think that
um these numbers are high these are
assume numbers by the New Hampshire
retirement system they also gave me
actual numbers for for a sort of subset
and that are a little bit lower and so
but but they weren't complete enough to
to really give you how much this year
how much that year I'm happy to take a
question
thank you both representative McGuire's
um
so the the people who leave in your
earlier uh
in your earlier presentation does that
factor in people who
go away and come back
because we we know a number of our
employees they're here for a couple
years whatever
especially with women who go away for
childbearing purposes uh they come back
later does it do your figures factor
that in
um thank you for the question I don't
exactly know so this is assume numbers
that the the retirement system gave me
so Mr Carlin probably could answer that
better but but in a sense I think of the
the the picture of employees like a
funnel right you start with a certain
number of hires and some leave after the
first year and some leave after the
second year and some leave after third
year like that maybe some come in and
now they would be in their second year
again right so something that sort but
but the number in service in each year
is declining right thank you
okay represent Mayberry and
representative shewitt
thank you madam chair
representative thank you for being here
today and I'd like to commend you and
your co-sponsors on this kind of Bill
the control for the generation coming in
wants that full control
I know that you don't have all of the
specifics yet
um but I'm curious
um if they will have the control that
I'm familiar with in the private sector
of going and choosing their Investments
not having a
um executive Council appointed board
that's chosen the Investments thank you
yes thank you for the question the
answer is absolutely yes because in
particular the state already has for 35
years what's called a Deferred
Compensation Plan it's called a 457 plan
and so employees can now volunteer it's
very similar to an IRA you can volunteer
to put pre-tax money into this plan and
you're given a menu of choices on how
you invest that money and it's all up to
you and it's run by somebody like Schwab
or Fidelity or one of those kind of
things yes so this this bill in in fact
puts the employee so there are employee
contributions and employer contributions
this puts the employee contributions
into the 457 plan we've had it for years
and years we've had it for decades this
creates a new plan and it's only
technically because of IRS creates a new
pot for the employer contribution but it
makes the two invested exactly the same
way according to the employees desire
okay representative
thank you madam chair good afternoon
representative McGuire good to see you
again
um the Bureau of Labor Statistics about
the number of people leaving work so on
and so forth were those just public
employees or was that all of them no I
think it's all
right thank you
and and again so that's why we have
those other numbers from what the
retirement system uses those are only
public employees and I could also give
you the numbers they gave from The
Experience survey which are a little bit
smaller okay but but they're not
they're not complete enough to know X
percent per year like that so thank you
for that clarification for
you thank you madam chair uh question
I like the the idea of you encouraging
people to invest in their own
retirement savings whatever whatever the
the money is going to be used for
but I I'm concerned and I want to know
how you address this is how you
prevent irresponsible Behavior
for example someone uh
withdraws all their money out of their
account so they can buy a fancy new car
and then when the car is gone and
they're
time of money that they were saving in
this plan is gone they end up in front
of us again looking for us to help bail
them out uh somehow so how do you deal
with that all right thank you for the
question so first of all the the plan
puts into the system it requires someone
to put into the system the same amount
of money that's being put into group one
retirements now right so
um so the amount going in is the same
now I believe that
um people cannot
withdrawal early they cannot withdraw
before termination there are certain
requirements in here about when you can
withdrawal and it's termination or age
such and such you know that kind of
thing so I don't think they can do what
you just described Mr Downing is in the
audience and so I think he can answer
that question a little more detail with
regard to the existing 457 plan thank
you
all right thank you
all right so
the other thing to think about so my
father for example born in 1923 had a
long career with IBM
and he loved the defined benefit plan
that IBM had he was into it right so he
would know
how much he was going to get Etc and
again it's a fixed income plan so it's
bad for inflation but also another
aspect of it is it's a kind of an
insurance plan because if you die early
the earnings the savings that you earned
and put into the plan go to others
right they don't they're not inheritable
by your heirs
right so it's a kind of insurance right
for the it's for the it's insurance for
the person who happens to live to 95 at
the expense of those who live to 65 or
that that sort of thing you see what I
mean and so I remember him telling me at
one point that they had statistics that
the the average person after they
retired from IBM they only lived five
years
right so they lived a very you know life
expectancy in those days was much less
right so people lived only just a few
years after retirement so it made sense
to have insurance right in case you
happen to live 20 years instead of five
right so those kind of plans made sense
but today we don't think about it that
way right we think we're going to retire
at 65 and we're going to live to 85
right so we need 20 years of income and
so
um so it this is the insurance aspects
of a defined benefit plan
aren't really right
uh for today's employees okay all right
now same thing uh one size fits all so
so
um a defined benefit plan everybody is
treated the same by the certain formula
but that not might not be right for
everybody you know some people might
choose to uh
have other Investments and other things
going on with their life with their
spouse and so on this plan lets people
invest the way they would be right for
them
all right now let's get to this big part
the guesswork
the problem with the defined benefit
plan is
and this is the problem so any further
questions maybe I should stop for
aggression here any further questions
about the the the drawbacks or this or
the benefits of defined benefit with
regard to the employee
no okay good all right so let's talk
about the drawbacks with regard to the
employer
okay so this plan defined benefit plan
and you know this well from your
experience on this committee
requires the employer to guess what's
going on in the future
right we have we have we're putting in
where we're expecting benefits and so on
to be a certain amount and then we
calculate therefore the employer has to
put in so much today to reach that point
but that's just a guess right it's an
educated guess you pay very expensive
people a lot of money to make that guess
but how good is it really right and
let's look at page three please
so page three is the piece of paper that
describes the unfunded liability that
this is what the legislature received in
2007.
okay so in 2007 when the uh unfunded
liability was look at the first line two
two billion 397 million okay that was
the unfunded liability at the time the
payroll at the time was two point also
2.9
billion okay
and here's what they projected for 2022.
so look at line 13.
so they expected that by 2022 our our
payroll would be up to 4.25 billion and
our unfunded liability would be 3.125
billion
okay so that's what they told people in
2007 you follow our plan this is what's
going to happen
all right now let's turn to page four
so it's on the back right page four is
this is the same piece of paper handed
out today
right so look at the Top Line our
current unfunded liability
5.7 billion
right in 2007 they predicted that today
it would be 3.125
so it's a lot higher
okay
our current payroll is only 3 billion
they thought that our payroll would be
4.225 billion you see what I mean so
this is why we're in trouble it's very
hard to predict the future
um and and even with the best people and
the best intentions and all that sort of
stuff right we're in much worse shape
now than the legislatures who sat in
this room 15 years ago thought we were
going to be at this point
okay and so I would say that that's
inherent in the in the in a defined
benefit plan
um I was here when Mr Carlin gave you
your introduction to the retirement
system
and he said something very profound that
day he was asked why are we in trouble
right how did we get here and what he
said was when you put several different
choices in front of the legislature
they're going to pick the cheapest one
all right that's human nature right so
so the legislature was given choices you
could pay it off over 30 years you could
pay it off 20 years right you could do
different things to pay it off right and
they picked the cheapest one for the
moment
and that's what we're constantly doing
we're constant and we do it today right
we ins if you look at this
um second piece of page four
um
well it's actually sorry it's it's not
shown on page four all right
look at um look at page three
so the notice how the total contribution
is 10.7 percent all the way down the
line the second column
right so that's the employer
contribution to pay off this unfunded
liability we still pay that roughly
today we pay a 10.7 percent contribution
to pay off the unfunded liability
that's the cheap way of doing it right
if you had a 30-year mortgage to pay
something off you would pay the same
dollar amount every year
not the same percentage amount every
year do you see what I mean so you would
pay a lot
you would pay more in the beginning and
less and the end inflation adjusted but
the plan we're actually using to pay off
the unfunded liability is back loaded
we are cheap now and we're planning to
pay a lot more later
all right that's not very sound uh
financially right I mean it's it's just
but it's it's human nature you know
we're incentivized to do the right thing
for our constituents today
because they're in you know they have
trouble today and you know people 10
years from now that that's them you know
so so the point is a defined
contribution plan can't be in trouble in
this way right it doesn't rely on
guesses it doesn't rely on figuring out
what the future is going to be
um we pay today for today's expenses
and and that's that okay so that's it so
any questions yeah go ahead
thank you madam chair thank you
representative McGuire for taking my
question
as I go back to these two charts on page
three in page four
can you tell me back in 2007
with the assumed rate of return was
it was higher no question about it yeah
I don't know the exact number but it was
we're currently assuming 6.75 percent
and then those days it was I don't know
eight or nine or something but that
itself is a guess right follow-up
follow-up
so is it fair to say the comparison of
the unfunded accrued liability using
2007 versus what it is today
is not similar because changing the
unfunded accrued like changing the
assumed rate of return changes that
number
no I I don't think so because again
those things are guesses right humans
made those guesses and so uh they
guessed wrong in some sense in 2007.
well they were they were very wrong
about the rate of return particularly
for the next year yeah and so
that's my point is my question is I'm
sorry the unfunded accrued liability
back in 2007 using if we if we used
eight percent today for the unfunded
accrued liability figure it wouldn't be
what it is in this chart so you cannot
compare the two because the numbers were
not the same at the
correct
yes thank you all right but anyway I
think you get my point other questions
thank you madam chair
so let's say that we adopted this
this concept this idea we changed it
over
how long would it take for us to Trail
this off or at least steady it
with the current retire retirement plan
and then implementing the new one thank
you for the question so first of all
this bill has nothing to do with how we
pay off the current unfunded liability
so the current unfunded liability would
still be paid in the same way you'd need
a new bill if you wanted to change that
but it's it's still be paid off in the
same way the same percentage of
employees salaries including these
employees in in group three all that
that that would go the same what would
happen is
for the group three employees
we would never be in trouble there would
never be any unfunded liability for them
compared to group one and group two
employees so to the extent that there's
fewer group one employees and more group
three employees
we have less problems in the future
right so that's that yeah
thank you madam chair
I think my my point is with these graphs
of how it's it's going up tremendously
and it was guesswork
my point is that if we were to implement
this plan at some point this starts to
study as the group threes coming in all
new employees coming into the state
right as as the retirement for group
group A and B start to to tick off
that's I just wanted to clarify my
question but I don't think you can
answer it at this point in time we
probably can't answer it but it's it
okay let me all right let me try to be a
little more detail
presumably so we think that we are
currently paying so we currently pay
over 20 of someone's salary toward the
retirement system that's what's going
into the retirement system for group one
all right of that money 10.7 percent is
to pay off the the 5.7 billion unfunded
liability and 9.3 percent or nine
whatever the other the rest is is going
for that employee's own benefits Okay so
that yeah that's actually not correct
the amount that's going toward the
currently earned benefits is about two
and a half percent isn't it
it's smaller than ten percent
yeah so what I'm talking about is the
total amount of funds going in right now
from the employee seven percent is going
in that is completely assigned to that
employee's own benefits okay and from
the employer two and a half percent is
going in for that employee's own benefit
so roughly nine and a half percent okay
the other 10.79 going in is to pay off
the unfunded liability and so this bill
doesn't change that it doesn't
it just redirects that nine points Point
uh uh nine and a half to group three for
their own benefits their own benefits
will be calculated in a different way
it's their own savings but the the 10.79
going to pay off the past that's the
same and unchanged okay
should I continue representative Schmidt
thank you so I'm a little bit confused
but that's pretty normal
um so the thing is that if you are
taking a a crop of new employees would
ordinarily be putting their
their share and this state share into
the current system to take them away
they're going to be in a separate
situation
then you don't have a
a fresh group of employees contributing
to the current situation as I understand
it and not quite no yeah I suppose is
there something wrong there because yes
to agree that you don't have like with
Social Security current payers or
funding I understand retirees yes thank
you for the question so so when we
calculate who's paying how much we owe
for the unfunded liability we include
everybody group one group two group
three okay all that we calculate how
much we have to pay to the unfunded
liability and there's a surcharge
currently 10.79 on group ones that goes
into unfunded liability okay
so that's that's the past that's paying
off the past so it's everybody paying
off the past in some sense including the
new people including the new people yes
okay but the new people their savings
for themselves is different right
compared to you gotcha okay thanks okay
other questions at this point
thank you very much thank you
um
all right now the other the other
drawback for employers so why in a sense
the trouble we're in now is because
people worked for us and earned benefits
20 years ago 15 years ago whatever and
we didn't pay enough for their
compensation
right they earned a salary they earned
benefits and we didn't at that time pay
enough which means those past taxpayers
paid too little for the work that they
got in exchange right so today's
taxpayers have to pay for today's
employees and the amount that past
taxpayers
didn't pay and and so the problem is the
longer we draw that out
the the worse the situation is because
because today's taxpayers are are more
and more removed from the work that was
done in the past you see what I mean so
so we need to pay things off as quickly
as possible and just as an aside
um I don't see uh representative O'Brien
here but today okay well his bill to pay
the seven and a half percent
Etc
um in committee I switched that to take
that same money and pay off the unfunded
liability right because we want to pay
off that unfunded liability as quickly
as possible and and and connect today's
taxpayers with today's employees right
so that what you know you're paying
today for the work you received today
that that that's a good principle I
think okay all right that's that's it
for defined benefit now let's talk about
the find country abusion plans okay we
already said a few of these things I'll
go quickly
um it's better positioned to keep up
with inflation right because it's not a
formula it's not fixed income it's it's
income based on investments so you have
at least some chance of keeping up with
inflation if you owned real estate if
you own stocks if you own things like
that those things tend to rise with
inflation so you you you can maybe keep
up
okay it's portable it has immediate
vesting you earn you earn something
today it's yours you take it with you if
you leave in two years or one year or
three years it's yours you put it in
your IRA or you keep it in the plan
however you want to do it okay it's
inheritable if somebody dies in a car
crash there uh that money that's their
own savings goes to their errors right
it doesn't go to other employees it's
not insurance
um
uh employees can customize their
Investments to their own liking and this
is also important it's reality okay
because in the current system
you earn your most benef your most
benefits happen based on what you do
late in your career
right if late in your career you get a
big increase or you work a lot of
overtime or something like that that
makes a big jump in the in your
retirement pay or you work a few more
years that makes a big jump in your
retirement pay but the amount in the
system that you contributed you and your
employer contributed comes early
right the early dollars are the most
important dollars because those grow for
40 years right the late dollars
are not as important right they're just
there right away and so
the the so because of that disconnect
people have the wrong incentives for how
they save
right whereas with a defined
contribution plan
people know they they feel that they're
early dollars are the most important so
so they have a good incentive to do the
right thing which is which is save early
in your career because you're going to
get 40 Years of growth right so that
that's what I wanted to say all right
um
so it can't go into debt so the defined
contribution plan you paid today
the expenses just like paying for
medical expenses and other expenses you
pay pension it goes into their plan it's
it's done today
and
um
yeah so uh it's fully funded by today's
taxpayers okay that's that's it for that
section on defined contribution anybody
have questions about what a defining
contribution plan is all right good and
then the bill itself so again we're just
starting with a very small group now
personally I think that group two
employees would benefit the most from
this kind of a plan why because they're
going to be retired for the they're
going to collect for the longest period
of time so if you're going to collect
for 30 years
you're you
inflation hurts you more
than if you collect for 10 years or 20
years you see what I mean so so
logically group two employees are the
ones that should most ones yeah all
right sorry about that all right but in
any case it this is a very small group
it's group one employees who work for
the state
um and are new brand new they've never
been in group one okay
um it has the exact same cost to the
employee and the employer as group one
um the the contributions go into our
plan the 457 plan that we've had for a
long long time
um it works well and
um we still paying the unfunded
liability and
um
oh and the expenses of the start there's
going to be some startup expenses and
the bill will
um put that into the general fund so so
um the general fund will will pay the
initial startup expenses I hope that got
into the amendment but I I didn't I
wasn't able to check okay any questions
about that
um representative lycus is going to talk
about the bill in more General more
detail okay all right personal note so
what I'm suggesting for the state is
what I myself have
okay and what the state has now is what
my wife has okay so I know personally
very much what's going on here
and I can say personally so my first job
I I started work in
1986. my first job was for the
University of California
um so it was a state state employee in
some sense and I have a 403 b which is
the same thing as this
um and
it's a fantastic plan I have a lot of
money in that plan you know I work for a
short period of time but because it was
40 well 30 something years ago it's
grown tremendously right so I have a
very from that a comfortable retirement
your chair on the other hand worked for
two different companies that had defined
benefit plans
and she worked for I don't know 10 years
for one and 13 years for the other
something like that and and her because
there are two different companies two
different plans so she doesn't get the
advantage of the high income times 20
years she has the high income times 10
years and a low income times 10 years
right but overall even that I worked for
fewer years than she did and my benefits
are much higher than hers okay so it's a
good plan I know it personally because
because I see it in my own family okay
um
all right I guess that's enough for me
the other questions representative
Fitzpatrick
I I too am
intimately
familiar with both types of plans and I
took
um a recipient of a deposit defined
contribution plan and I understand their
their benefits
and I'm I'm familiar with cities in the
country that have switched as as this
committee may not know there are many
cities throughout the U.S that have
their own Retirement Systems separate
from a state one and uh I'm thinking of
the city of Troy Michigan for instance
uh and when Troy Michigan switched they
also offered their employees who were in
their defined benefit plan
to take their action their actual aerial
benefit and transfer it to the to then
it was
icmarc which is the international City
County management association's
retirement Corporation and they run a
401a program uh is there any
consideration for for that a program uh
for this Bill thank you for the question
um sort of the bill forces new state
group one employees into this plan right
it allows other group one employees to
effectively quit and take what they
would get out of group one and put it in
this plan and continue in this plan if
they prefer that so yes there's there's
a little bit of an option that way and I
would think that employees that that are
fairly young right that are in their
second third year might want to do that
those that are further along might not
it's really up to them so okay follow up
just one more uh has there also been any
thought of making it optional in other
words you have a you're still offering
the
traditional defined benefit plan but a
new employee can choose immediately into
the defined
contribution track
yes thank you for the question we did
not consider that
um we're a little concerned about
expenses in the sense that if the number
of people in a plan isn't enough to pay
the employee you need to run it et
cetera Etc there's some issues there so
um one other thing I'd like to point out
the University of New Hampshire has this
kind of a plan and has had for roughly
25 years the financial officer of the
university is Catherine provencher and
if you want to she was very receptive to
my calls and so if you want to talk to
her about their experiences and so on
which are all positive that would be
another source of information
uh Representatives Weiler and Santa
nastasso if you don't mind Mr Savage has
a plane so he's got to leave early so I
would like to call on him
okay thank you very much Thomas Savage I
also um I have handouts uh
I'd be I'd be happy to pass those around
as well
thank you very much
could be enough for everybody
yes and uh since you're giving us your
written testimony you don't need to read
it just give us the highlights certainly
well thank you very much for the
opportunity to testify and to speak with
you all today
um you know this topic is of such
interest to Alec because
um unfunded pension liabilities and the
rapid growth of unfunded pension
liabilities is of great concern across
the country
so we're here today to offer
um an education to offer and educate
um on some of our pension research which
is published annually in a report titled
unaccountable and unaffordable and that
is uh publicly available on our website
I'm here today excuse me could you
introduce yourself to those who did my
apologies my apologies my name is Thomas
Savage I'm the research director with
the center for State fiscal reform at
the American legislative exchange
Council or Alec
um for those of you who don't know Alec
is the nation's largest nonpartisan
voluntary membership organization of
state legislators
Alec and its members are dedicated to
advancing the principles of limited
government free markets and federalism
where a forum for stakeholders to
exchange ideas and to develop real
state-based policy solutions to
encourage growth preserve Economic
Security and protect hard-working
taxpayers because of Alex focus on state
policy ideas Alec has a wealth of
experience analyzing state public
Pension Plan programs and determining
types of policies that ensure their
solvency
um so the Crux of my written testimony
today is to offer examples of pension
reform across the country particularly
the case studies of Alaska Michigan and
Oklahoma
in 2005 Alaska passed legislation
enrolling new state employees and
teachers into a defined contribution
plan a study from the reason Foundation
found that by making these reforms
Alaska saved over 40 million dollars
from 2006 to 2016. the problems in
Alaska however stem from the state not
properly funding the closed defined
benefit plans
in the Years following pension reform
the state failed to make the full
necessary contributions to the
closed-defined benefit plan and did not
change its payment schedule to speed up
paying off those liabilities the lesson
from Alaska is that you must keep making
the full required contributions to the
closed defined benefit plan after
reforms are made
in 1996 Michigan was actually the first
state in the nation to close its defined
benefits state employees retirement
system and enroll new hires in a defined
contribution plan
similarly the Public School Employees
Retirement System or mipsers
enrolled new hires in a defined
contribution plan in 2017. the mipsers
plan Auto enrolls new hires into into a
defined contribution plan but new
teachers have the choice of opting into
a hybrid with which is a mix of a
defined contribution and defined benefit
plans
the reforms in Michigan like in Alaska
drastically improved plan solvency and
saved taxpayers money a study conducted
by Richard Dreyfus in the Mackinac
Center found that Michigan's reforms
saved taxpayers anywhere from 2.3
billion dollars to 4.3 billion dollars
in unfunded liabilities and improved
political incentives of pension funding
a separate study from the reason
Foundation found that the 1996 reforms
saved Michigan over two billion dollars
from 1996 to 2016.
in 2015 Oklahoma closed the defined
benefit Public Employees Retirement
System excuse me we're having trouble
hearing you oh pardon me you have you
have to be close to this Pardon Me
microphone to fight all right
oh I was in 2015 Oklahoma closed the
defined benefit public employees
retirement system and enrolled new hires
into its defined contribution plan known
as the Pathfinder plan
since the recent reforms pers funding
ratio has steadily increased year over
year by making the necessary reforms to
take a proactive stance towards paying
down existing unfunded liabilities pers
improved its funding and reduced pension
debt at an impressive rate
um these states show that pension reform
is possible by transitioning new hires
into defined contribution plans these
States helped improve improved
retirement system solvency and slowed
the growth of pension debt uh once again
Alec is grateful for the opportunity to
testify before this committee
and thank you all for your time and
attention to the critical importance of
unfunded liabilities and I'll be happy
to take any questions
thank you are there any questions from
the committee representative Dolan thank
you thank you thank you madam chair and
uh this is maybe a question for
for you or our previous speaker
um
when these when these Define
contribution plans uh are utilized by
the employees that the I assume the
money goes into an account somewhere
either a private account or you know a
private business account
uh is that account guaranteed
by the state
um so it depends on the state depends on
the plan but normally that is that money
is put into an account like a 401k a 403
b or 457 deferred contribution plan or a
401a
um
but yeah that money is uh locked in
there it is the employees money and in
some cases the state will offer to match
the employees contribution up to a
certain percentage but yeah once the
money is in that account it belongs
entirely to the employee and
um no one else can touch it yes and the
state does not necessarily guarantee the
performance if so if the employee makes
poor choices
that happens I think in more of the
balance of the what's in the what's in
the account so if the organization
that's caretaking the caretaker of the
account goes belly up or whatever uh how
does the uh how's the employee guarantee
that that money ah is still there that's
that I believe Mr Downing will be able
to answer
because it it depends on the plan and he
has information about New Hampshire's
plan okay thank you other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much Mr Savage thank you for your time
uh representative
that seed
um Weiler would you uh care to uh
next time
thank you madam chair members of the
committee representative Ken Weiler uh
Rockingham 13.
um
I've heard a lot of the details on this
bill
which I re I support
so I'm more or less offer a personal
experience that I think is is called is
certainly relevant
I work for American Airlines as a pilot
from 1970 to 2001.
and I had because of my union we had
both an a fund and a b fund one was
defined benefit the other one was
defined contribution
they put seven and a half percent
of my pay into a defined benefit
they put four percent into a defined
contribution now unlike the other
airlines that I have friends with
I was able to take both of those in a
lump sum
most of my other Airline colleagues all
they could take an Alum sum was the
Define contribution the defined benefit
remained in
with the airline
when I took the money out in 2001 now
granted
1990 as we saw looking at reviewing the
retirement system as I always did
was very good
for the for the
um
for the stock market
it was averaging close to nine percent a
year
then it dropped off and the 2000s to
about half of that
but
so I retire with two lump sums
which one do you think was bigger
the defined contribution was 60 percent
even though only four percent went in
and seven and a half percent went into
the other seven and a half percent gave
me forty percent of my lump sum
and the four percent gave me sixty
percent I thought that was amazing and I
was so delighted that I did have both
and had a defined contribution and it
always tells me of course that was a
very good decade prior to my retirement
and it isn't always so and I've always
been critical of our retirement system
because it has so much variation
one year it gets 26 percent the next
year it gets minus six
none of my
managers have had that kind of thing but
I think it's very significant when we
look at things like that and there's a
personal experience and I know some of
you other have as well and you know
I guess I don't need to repeat all the
benefits since there's other people
waiting to talk of the defined
contribution in my mind it's it's
portable it increases with inflation
um even though you take the risk we as
people trying to do the government
budget appreciate the fact that it's not
going to go into a deep deficit because
the risk is with the employer but so is
the upside so I'd be happy to answer any
questions but I think Define
contributions are a great system and
that's why I think so many other states
as Mr Savage has said have transferred
to them thank you thank you and I'd like
to congratulate you on your students as
an investor because that's what made the
difference
yes and now I have more than I started
with even though I've been taking big
months out every year yep glad to hear
it and you have anyone have any
questions
seeing none thank you very much
okay representative Lucas
thank you for the record I'm
representative Tony leckis representing
Hillsboro 38 the towns of Hudson and
Litchfield and so my intent here is to
go over the bill
in the various sections to kind of
explain how this works and
the first part is defining who is in
this
the new defined contribution plan
and we wanted to start out small
and see what the experience is so this
it's just
um
employees and that's employee is sort of
the term of Art in the retirement system
of the state not political subdivision
so the change here is it it takes
um you know any person who becomes a
political subdivision employee
or a teacher permanent policeman and
permanent fireman the group two people
um
will remain in the defined benefit plan
and people who are um
further down
other state employees so that's other
than teachers and and group two
who begin after uh July of 2024 she'll
join what this is calling group three
which is the defined contribution plan
all right so the next section is the
part that requires that the employers
continue to pay based on the gross
salary
um the past debt in uh the unfunded
liability similar to an earlier Bill
where if the employee if they get rid of
the position they have to continue to do
it as well
if the people are no longer you know in
the or the future people are not in
the defined benefit plan they still have
to pay towards the past debt
and then
um the rest of it is just setting up
the plan
if you look here there's a commission on
page two line seven a commission needs a
deferred compensation commission under
RSA 101b that is the
previously mentioned plan that's
voluntary any any employee can put money
into it if they want
and it is a defined contribution plan
that's been going for around 35 years
so that is well well established
um
and further down it actually establishes
that Define contribution plan
and it requires that um
any rules meet
the federal requirements to make it
valid under Section 401a and 414 D of
the Internal Revenue code and that's
what among other things allows the
contributions to be tax-exempt
you know if you're a federal taxes it
has to meet those requirements the same
as a 401k a plan that an employer might
offer
okay
um
towards the bottom there it it provides
the standard rule making
um under 541a so that
the the executive director can adopt
rules on how the whole thing works under
this that standard
purpose
um
the plan maybe doesn't have to be it may
be contracted with a third party
administrator
um I know you know I don't know maybe
some companies administering their own
401ks I'm not familiar with one I had
one for many years which you know they
had did it through Fidelity there's
others that handle it
and powers of the commission and it uh
basically
goes through and defines the powers that
let them basically operate the plan if
people have questions about anything
particular
I'll deal with them I need to point out
on page three line 25 while 26 and then
at the bottom of that page where it
mentions the percentage
of the employee contribution and the
employer contribution this is an error
we got the amendment back late yesterday
and
the OLS didn't appear to put in what we
wanted what that will be is identical to
the current rates for the employee and
employer contribution for the current
plan
that is it still is a minimum of seven
percent from the employee correct that
is the seven percent that they put into
the defined benefit plan plus whatever
voluntary contributions they may wish to
add and the employer will put in two and
a half percent or so yeah it's I think
it's like 2.48 or it's slightly under
two and a half percent yeah I believe
but the intent is for that to be
identical and we're not standing up a
new plan this is basically
well it's
the employee part is going to be under
the existing plan that's in 101b
there is
it's a little complicated because the
IRS requires the employee and the
employer contributions to go technically
into separate funds
but the way it's to be administered is
that that's going to be basically
invisible to the employee their
decisions on how Investments are made
would apply in the same manner to each
fund but underneath there has to be that
structure to satisfy the federal
government
okay
okay and
then the withdrawal rules
um are on the the last page
and it's the standard things that exist
for 401k if you have a 401k or an IRA
you can't just take the money out on a
whim
at least not with plans that I'm
familiar with you know termination of
employment retirement you reach 59 and a
half
and there's some other special hardship
ones
um you know extraordinary medical
expenses or certain other things that
the IRS permits early withdrawals
but um
you know but but you can't just go buy a
nice car face you know with your uh what
should be your retirement savings and
then there's a section on required
distributions
this is again uh to go along with the
IRS rules if anybody is a has Ira or
401K especially if you're retired and
living off of it
you may be aware there's a minimum
required distributions based on your age
and some other factors and that has to
apply to these plans as well
and as was mentioned when it's starting
up
there won't be the money in it
originally initially for startup and the
early Administration fees and so that
would come from the general fund we
don't have no fiscal note on it yet as I
said this amendment came out yesterday
late
but then they will be born
by the plan by the contributions go to
the plan once it gets going
or by the general fund if a future
legislature decides to include future
legislature can do whatever it like but
I'll be glad to answer questions
okay representative shrew
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh going back to the
era
um You referred to on page three uh 24
to 28
that's going to be corrected
yes there will have to be another
amendment there's uh bill could you go
over that one more time slowly sure
currently
on the current retirement plan the the
group one employees are required to
contribute seven seven percent of their
salary to the retirement plan that will
remain the same
but instead of going into the current
defined benefit plan it would go into
the new Define well not new it's the
existing plan
okay and then the employer it's
approximately two and a half percent
which is I I whatever the number is
it'll be identical to the current number
and that will go into the plan and as I
mentioned strange IRS rules it
technically goes into a separate fund
but it's invested in the same way as uh
is the one on the plan under 101b so the
error is on line 34 where it says seven
percent and also 26.
right 26 is correct thank you but um
line 34 is the employer shall contribute
uh whatever the current
is approximately two and a half
so this is a fairly stingy employer
match yes representative true thank you
madam chair just so
under this new plan
the uh the new employee
is paying nothing into the New Hampshire
Retirement System
uh they are not however their employer
is still going to pay
the normal amount towards the unfunded
liability 10-7 or whatever yep thank you
other questions
thank you very much
thank you members of the committee uh my
name is representative Santo nastasso
representing the towns of ringe Jaffrey
and Dublin
uh just briefly want to remind the
committee about the New Hampshire
Constitution part one article 36 economy
being a most essential virtue in all
states especially in a young one no
pension shall be granted but in
consideration of actual services and
such pensions ought to be granted with
great caution by the legislator and
never for more than one year at a time
so this article is clearly intended to
prevent the state from going to the debt
over pensions by forcing them to only be
granted at one year at a time and that's
exactly what a defined contribution plan
such as the one in House Bill 559
accomplishes each year the state
contributes to the pension benefit
earned by the employee in that year and
there's no future liability
so this constitutional provision has
been ignored uh resulting in the
situation we have now billions of
dollars in debt and uh a check at the
live State Library revealed it's never
been litigated so obviously I support
the bill
thank you
any questions
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question so
in looking at this this is just your
opinion it has not been litigated and
has not been found unconstitutional
correct uh it has not been litigated but
uh I don't think that part one article
36 you know is too complicated it seems
like it would be out of violation
so this is your opinion well yeah so
technically that's correct
thank you
Mr Carlin you're
here
and actually do you think Mr Downing
should join you or are you uh
your separate issues
okay separate thank you representative
Carl I'm not Mr Carl on that
foreign
thank you madam chair again for the
record my name is Marty Carlin
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system uh the retirement
system doesn't have a position on this
bill
um I had a chance to look at the
amendment uh briefly
um since since it was uh drafted uh
yesterday afternoon uh this actually
takes a lot of nhrs's role out of the
plan and the plan Administration for
this defined contribution plan is more
with the with the Deferred Comp plan
um in in the state which is separate
from nhrs
um just some general comments uh in the
initial proposal for this bill the there
was no provision for capturing the
liabilities for a declining pool of
state employees
um this amendment would address that by
having employers pay us the the unfunded
portion of the existing employer rate on
the salary for these if that wasn't in
there then there'd be a smaller smaller
pool of group one employees mainly
Municipal and those costs would be
shifted over to the municipalities but
that's not the case here
just based on some prior testimony just
just a couple things to sort of clarify
as as
um I think there was a question about
what's the difference between a defined
benefit plan and a defined contribution
and the one thing that I hadn't heard
was it it basically it's risk a defined
benefit plan the risk is on the employer
to make up the difference to fund the
plan on a defined contribution plan it's
on the individuals I think
representative Gerhard asked early well
what happened if someone you know didn't
invest well and and you know I guess
Public Assistance would be the answer
for that
um you know that you know the government
tends to be the last resort of services
for the Indigent
there are some pension systems around
the country that have sort of a shared
risk model New Hampshire does not
there's some language in the statute
that could lead to that 30 years for 20
20 years from now but it's it's until
this liability is paid down so so
there's there's different ways to do
that
um but this bill essentially would just
have us be collecting you know the
unfunded rate putting that towards you
know the pension debt and and
stabilizing the employer contribution
rates and there really isn't anything
else necessarily that we'd be doing uh
with this so it's so it's very limited
and you know to confirm and clarify the
current components of the uh employee
contribute employer contribution rate
for employees is 2.48 towards the normal
cost as stated in 10.79 towards the
unfunded there's also a medical subsidy
rate component piece that that's
essentially a cash in cash out exchange
with admin Services they may have some
commentary on that but but the
retirement system doesn't
um have any any concern with that that
piece of it so
um really this is very straightforward
and our role is limited to it but I
would be glad to answer any questions if
I can
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair uh so Mr Carlin uh
even though the nhrs is not taking a
position on the bill your analysis of
the the structures that are being put in
place in this bill suggests to me that
you that your opinion is that this is a
common sense structurally sound uh
apparatus for creating a defined
contribution plan in addition to the
existing defined benefit plan that we
currently have I I think that you know
that maybe you know a little bit of an
overstatement at this point because we
just had to you know we just got this
amendment yesterday and then there there
are and I was going to say this about
the original version of the bill there
are a lot of different uh Internal
Revenue code and other legal Provisions
regarding the setup and administration
of a defined contribution plan that are
very different from a defined benefit
plan and I think you know where
hey we're kind of out of this one but we
also don't have the staffs who are
qualified to comment on those levels is
this this might be something that would
benefit from review by an outside
Council from a financial services firm
that does this for a living to make sure
there aren't any missing pieces or
anything like that our our commentary is
limited to the fact that our our primary
concern that we would have spoken to
when the original bill was that
declining pool of state employees
putting upward pressure on the the
employee employer contribution rate for
employees for municipality so you know
and also closing the plan out would um
lead to
um if you know without the unfunded
piece being paid could lead to us having
to reduce our our return assumptions
based on the fact that we'd be more of
paying out benefits than enrolling new
members so so this but
you know strictly speaking this is
outside of nhrs so we wouldn't be in a
position to comment saying you know good
bad or indifferent because it's it would
be sort of a standalone thing and you
know in parallel to us but not part of
us
follow up follow up so uh you you've
referred to the uh
original
bill which I uh I take it that that
represent Dan Maguire as substituting
the uh the amendment for the original
bill so I'm I'm not considering the
original bill at all because uh this is
what we've what we've been hearing about
with the exception of the mistake on
page three
um but but uh it seems like it's a very
this is a different breed of cat than
the original belt very much so
representative so and you cross off our
fiscal note on the original bill it
doesn't track with anything in this one
it would have to be completely
re-analyzed if this version passes the
house you know we would have you
actually look at it again and see if
there are any potential funding
pressures that this would create that
you know we're not aware of on the
surface you know with you know 12 hours
to look 24 hours to look at the
amendment but it it follow up but at
first blush you don't look at the
amendment and say my God look at page
three you know that the whole thing
drives off the cliff and so forth so
this is a this is a fundamentally
different breed of cat and seems at
first blush without your final
imprimatur uh to be a fundamentally
sound concept I I I will say that you
know initial legal review and review by
others we didn't see any
flaming dumpsters or whatever the word
you'd want to use you know that like oh
this is a you know this is a deal
breaker this is you know this can't work
because of all right X you know I'm not
looking forward
always always right I'm not looking for
your signature on the back of these but
it does
cover the unfunded liability
appropriately and does not decrease
these the people in the plan so
drastically that you have to change your
Investments yeah that this would affect
future future employees who would not be
members of nhrs I wouldn't be
appropriate for us to speak about the
merits of it for them they're not
members it doesn't
try and tie it back
representative true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
earlier you had started throwing out
some some percentages I think one of
them was a 2.84
if 0.48
could you repeat those anymore what were
they again I'm sure I've written them
down a million times I don't know what
they are yeah no problem okay so the the
when we get back to the pension 101
stuff we talk about the normal cost
which is the cost of the benefits as
they're recruit for an existing employee
okay and the actual recalculated that
out to be 9.48 of pay
so the member pays seven percent of that
and then currently under RH the employer
pays the remaining 2.48 of the normal
cost to fund those benefits going
forward so 7 plus 2.48 is the quote
normal cost of the plan currently and
then there's the the unfunded piece
which is is the big you know probably 78
of what employers are paying or more is
that the the 10.79 and that that's what
we would still be receiving from the
state for employees participating in
this plan so that wouldn't go into their
account it wouldn't be part of their
defined contribution that's just the
state
continuing to pay its obligation toward
the unfunded for them for the employee
group and but in in the uh distant
future when the unfunded liability is
paid down to the point that the employer
rate goes below seven percent total than
it is in statute that the employee rate
will be adjusted so that they the
employer rate will never go below the
employee rate or
yeah so that that's something that it's
another 15 years out so we can ignore it
for this week that was the risk sharing
piece that I was referencing yes
all right anyone else represent goalie
thank you madam chair Marty thank you
for taking my question
so we're looking at the difference of
the employer paying the same rate that
they would whether it's defined
contribution to fine benefit we're
looking at a plan difference correct
yeah the the the the I think the stated
intent despite the text was that the
state would be paying the same
percentage of pay for folks in the DC
plan as they're currently paying for
folks in the DB plan
and that would mean that defined benefit
versus defined contribution is
defined benefit
the risk is on the employer not the
employee who has to worry about the
market going up and down come time if
they're looking to retire on a year like
last year when the market tanked 20
percent debating whether or not they
have to hold off a year or two to recoup
their money that they would get the
benefit in a defined benefit versus the
fine contribution correct yes thank you
okay other questions
representative shewitt
thank you madam chair
um
the impetus on this bill is employees
going forward but my concern is current
employees who are in defined benefit and
current retirees
I'm assuming the way that the current
plan works the contributions similar to
social security cover the people that
are employee I'm sorry retired because
the expenses generally get higher due to
inflation how do you see funding for
retirees in the defined benefits plan
going forward if all the new funds are
going towards the new employees
but if
since none of the new employees would be
accruing benefits in nhrs if the state
is committed to paying the unfunded rate
going forward they're they're using that
the covered payroll of the folks not in
the plan to to
pay down the unfunded as if they were in
the plan so you know so it you know it
you know that it's they're they're
substituting well substituting they're
still meeting their obligation toward
the unfunded and that that's what those
are the benefits that are accrued by
people already so you know as long as
that the state's commitment to pay that
unfunded rate goes forward you know we
can you know it you know like I said
there may be some you know marginal
impacts on the size of the active member
population things like that but the
actuator would have to look at that and
tell me about them because I you know
I'm not sure what there may be and you
know it's
um you know there you know there could
be other again like sort of
esoteric factors that would have some
impact on funding but you know right now
we're not aware of any but you know we
would
find that out
okay represent goalie thank you madam
chair just one more quick question as we
go about employer rates and where we are
with the unfunded approved liability I I
think I've heard a lot of agreement
amongst those who testified earlier that
the unfunded accrued liability was
because of actions here of this of the
legislature and decisions that they had
made previously leading up to that
correct plus the market Behavior yeah I
I that's I think that represents the
testimony there are other factors that
led to where we are you know in in terms
of 2007 versus
um 2021 and I don't I don't I I
appreciate representative McGuire wasn't
making an Apples to Apples but you know
that was June 30th of 2007 so that was
before the great financial crisis uh and
before we lower the assumed rate of
return three times and made a
proportionate reduction to our payroll
growth assumption at those three
junctures so you know it for
illustrative purposes yes assumptions
change and you know he made that point
that was that was accurate but a lot has
happened since you know then and that
that's you know there were policy
decisions in the 80s and 90s that
started building up the liability but
then we've had other other you know
Market issues and other and lowering the
assume rate of return which is
essentially becoming more conservative
and being less risky we're charging the
employers up you know paying us now
instead of paying us later
um you know with that so we would argue
that that's that's a sound approach and
it also reflects you know the decline
and
um you know the value of fixed income
Investments over the last 15 to 20 years
interest rates had inflation we're have
we're seeing inflation now finally but
um you know the interest rates on you
know bonds who are at record lows for
you know more you know the better part
of 15 years so that another reason why
we had to ratchet down the assumed rate
of return a lot of
consumer rate of return and things like
that are all Market dependent you know I
didn't look up you know 1970 to 2001 how
the Dow did you know and representative
Weiler's career but you know somebody
who started in 1975 and retired in all
five it might have been different it
might have been better might have been
worse but there's there's a lot of
endpoint dependency on when you have
your Investments invested and where you
have what buckets you put them in
um
and where I'm going with this is as not
this
what has not
pass legislatures legislation helped out
the employer rates by smoothing and
getting rid of spiking and some of those
increments that has eased the up and
down flows of employer rates yes there's
a lot of you know you know putting aside
the benefit changes which we talked a
lot about this morning there were a lot
of foundational about Actuarial funding
you know amortization periods layout
amortization smoothing you know that
that you know would you know the goal is
to stabilize employer rates and you know
we would never say that all assumptions
are going to be met every year but what
the expectation is if you know they are
close you know on some are better than
others the employer contribution rates
we're seeing now will be relatively
stable as a percent of pay through 2039
that's the goal
um you know we would when if we had to
lower the assume rate of return that
would push them up but if we if we could
keep all of our assumptions in place and
they were they tracked you know
reasonably with reality you know rates
aren't going to go down until 2040.
um you know because 5 billion of the 5.7
is is on a pay down by 2039 but that's
the way it's you know that it's and
drawn up on paper you know and then when
you run the play you know maybe you have
to you know break off the route or
something and and things change but that
that's that's the goal of the funding
method we're on now and that that
funding method also was back loaded as
representative McGuire mentioned so the
first 10 or 12 years we weren't even
paying off the interest on the unfunded
we just hit that crossover point in 21
so we'll be seeing bigger chunks coming
off
proportionally as we get closer to 2039
yes thank you madam chair so as I
understand it
um
the new employees that only they have
the option
or maybe they don't the option for the
defined contribution plan
but they will not have an option to join
the defined benefit plan is that correct
um if I'll I'll speak for state
employees
um you know because the bill refers to
that right now uh full-time permanent
employees state employees are in
mandatory enrollment in nhrs there is a
deferred plan that Mr Downing will speak
about and uh and all employees at any
stage of their career including at the
beginning have the option to participate
in that plan tape you know take you know
payroll deductions in in that um it's a
457 but it's essentially a defined
contribution the member chooses the
allocation and there's a you know so
that that's the current landscape for
state employees now follow up is it is
there any plan or thoughts to say that
at some point there will no longer be a
defined benefit plan and your only
option as an employee is the defined
contribution this this bill says that if
you're hired after July 1st 2024 that is
your only options yes thank you
okay any any other questions
thank you very much
Mr Downing
good morning
Madam chairman yes Excuse me yes foreign
thank you man if you have a question to
the chair
is talking about state employees and
because
towns uh division of the state
no this would not include Municipal
Employees as written and the intent is
to start it up with the state and
possibly offer an option for the
municipalities to enroll their
uh employees if they wish but other
employees I mean police by a teachers
at the moment it is only for state
government employees which is does not
include teachers
thank you and that's
good afternoon Madam chairman uh
actually a pleasure to be here because
the last time I was scheduled to testify
I ended up getting coveted and and
didn't so I'm happy to be here uh rather
than uh between somewhere between the
floor and the couch
um I had some input with representative
McGuire on the original Bill like
everyone else I got that at 5 50 last
night so I have not had the benefit of
uh discussion with Council and right now
as executive director of the Deferred
Compensation commission and in
consultation with the chairman of the
commission right now we take no position
but we may in the future yeah uh I the
reason I called you at this point is to
answer any questions the committee may
have about how the
defined con your Deferred Compensation
Plan works because it's an integral part
of the bill as amended and so I'm sure
there are questions
representative Dolan for example has one
right now yes thank you madam chair uh
then my question that I was hitting at
earlier
was the any guarantees or any what
security
do employees have that join the
um Define contribution plan that they're
actually going to get their money that
they're not at the at some risk
um the the situation that I believe
you're referring to is is if the and it
this will go out to a third party
administrator the state is not going to
create a record-keeping system
um even large states like Florida and
Texas they they Farm these plans out
um so in the event of say a insurance
company a who's The Record Keeper they
go Belly Up
you're protected the Assets in the plan
the employee assets are protected
because it's in a custodial agreement or
a trustee agreement it's kept separate
and is not a part of any obligation of
the insurance company so if if there's
no money held within the insurance
company that could be subject to claims
there are also Federal Insurance
programs for brokerages and insurance
companies to
make sure that if there was a theft
involved the
people who entrusted their money to that
business would get that money back
I I have a
a story if you will similar to
representative Weiler's story he had to
leave up evidently
but I have a American Airlines
uh
friend who has gone through his
retirement system and had money in it to
find a contribution plan but also a lot
of his money was
or his retirement was staked in a
defined benefit plan
now
he lost the money in the defined
contribution plan through
a messy divorce which I don't want to
get into social Engineers beyond our
scope
my question is
do we are we going to be offering any
protection or uh it you know if if a
defined benefit plan goes away
and the defined Compensation Plan is
eaten up by some social event
what you know
our employees can uh really get jobs at
the local grocery store but what what
beyond that is the disaster scenario
protection for them uh or are we going
to build anything into our defined
contribution plans that will not put the
entire plan at risk for a social issue
like a divorce or whatever well if if I
was married and got a divorce I'm in the
pension plan
um
my my spouse is going to get a cut of
that
so there's no there's no protection from
that I mean that's up to a judge
um and you know Divorce Court the judges
can in the case of a divorce allocate
either a defined benefit or a defined
contribution plan
and it has happened they call it Quadro
it's qualified
uh
court ordered distribution and you know
there's there's a there's a uh division
of assets
and that's subject to our plan in fact
any retirement plan uh is subject to
that thank you
anyone else
uh I have one representing from a former
state employee who'd like to testify his
tools experience
go ahead
trying to
answer thank you
um I'm since
I don't mean to put you on the spot go
ahead
um I recall we've heard the mention that
there would be startup costs to this
which I assume would be borne by the
state I recall when a plan going to
Define contribution was
proposed previously that the startup
costs were so huge that that was
basically why it was discarded at that
time do you recall what that amount was
uh representative shewitt okay I recall
that when we considered it and we were
contemplating closing the defined
benefit plan that caused a major charge
to the defined benefit plan because it
was assumed that since they would not be
getting any new contributions they would
have to invest more conservatively to
make make the payouts that is
which was turned out to be a
tremendously large number that is not
relevant because this bill only takes
off a portion of the employees the
defined benefit plan is still in
in existence it's still being funded new
teachers new firemen Etc are being added
all the time so it is not a closed
system and those costs do not apply
okay and I I remember that pretty well
it's different costs so because that
prior bill was a mandatory join the 457
plan 457 plan all expenses right now
we're able to pay uh afforded by the
participants in the plan there's no
State money involved
so that was just that was just putting
more participants into the deferred comp
plan so the fiscal note we had to do was
simply programming the payroll system
for mandatory contributions which is
something we'd have to do again the cost
back then I I believe in the fiscal note
was 68 to 80 000 to get it going so
those costs that would be a cost on this
plan too
because of the original language the
fiscal note did go to um a retirement
system if the chair or some other entity
redirects the fiscal note to das to my
attention we'd be happy to try to get
those uh that and additional costs well
the fiscal note will have to be
amended at some point when we
vote this out of committee which I do
not expect to be this week and it may
not be this year
I'm happy to assist all right thank you
um it
just a a couple of other things that I
have I can't say concerns but points of
interest I guess at this point
if I may please
um I thank the sponsor for not putting
my name in the bill and just executive
director
it's the position not the person yeah
well
uh
so I I would first think unlike the
pension system
the the 457 plan which operates more or
less like a
401k for for public employees not an IRA
um
is is uh it has to have a planned
document and so with this because
regardless of testimony we are creating
a new plan there has to be a new plan
for those employer contributions the the
testimony is correct that to the
employee
um the same company or a compatible
company that record keeps the employer
contributions is going to be able to
show on their defined contribution
statements so to the employee there
doesn't see much and you do that for two
reasons one it just helps the employee
if you if you put the employer
contribution into the 457 it counts
against the limits that the employee can
give
so you really you're taking away that
ability to accelerate the savings
uh for them so you you account that in a
separate bucket
um
so just just one point on on
uh
second page three
as I was saying the plan has a planned
document the pension system the pension
law is the planned document that's why
it's so detailed of how the pension
Works 457 and this 401a would have an
IRS approved plan document that's about
60 pages that contains every single IRS
law and regulation so it would be a
it we do not need to do administrative
rules because we have the basic
parameters are in the Bill of who's
eligible and what their rate will be but
everything else will be taken care of by
the planned document so my request would
be that that 541a
a requirement to do rules would be waive
or taken out
um
again we've talked about the two percent
there's uh 2.48 there are other states
that do this Oklahoma was mentioned they
have a hundred percent or very close to
it pension funding so when they went
with this and a mandatory
um you know they they indeed do have
this structure
Pennsylvania which is another state I
looked at they have this plan as one of
their many options
uh for a new employee being hired
um they have seven and a half percent
for the for the employee and they have
three and a half percent
um by the mandatory contribution from
the state and both of those go into the
401a plan so there's no linkage at all
to the 457 except they're record kept by
the same company which saves money and
the the employees can see those both
plans on
both on the one statement
um but it doesn't count there's no
counting against the limits on the 457.
that can that continues to be a
supplemental voluntary plan
initial funding I mean uh it it's uh
this is very thoughtful in Pennsylvania
my discussion with the executive
director there
which is in the pension system
is that
they guarantee they the state had to
guarantee to The Record Keeper that they
would do they would cover all costs of
the record keeping and the plan for five
years
and and that's why they got bids they uh
you know the Record Keeper is going okay
what happens after two years
and if the plan still isn't enough
it are we going to have to put
prohibitively expensive
um fees on the plan to run it
so might I suggest this that there's
consideration on the fees that after an
extension of Beyond two years or
um that it gradually state state
um
funding gradually decreases to like 75
percent 50 and then 25 and so you still
have an end date but there's a
transition period because I do not
believe the plan would be large enough
to support
um all of the costs within two years
okay I do I think the transition uh uh
date is doable
um under a state we would go out to bid
and add this on
um
we have to uh by IRS law and the cus and
and The Prudent investment rules we
would select just like a 401k the
investment options uh it might not be
identical to what's in the in the 457
plan but very close I mean
so some of the Investments would be the
same
I don't have off the top of my head what
this type of plan would generating fees
we have to keep those expenses separate
um right now I mean my salary is fully
reimbursed on a quarterly basis to the
state
by assessments and money drawn down from
the plan so we that's planned money
belonging to 457 we have to be very
careful not to mingle that with expenses
for the new plan but that can be done
questions yes representative goalie
you're not hearing
you red there we go
that's better
I had too many on I think
yeah it sounds like you've done a little
bit of research on what other states
that have similar plans
are paying into the system and I heard
one of your figures was 3.4 percent from
Pennsylvania or wherever
and that seems
like a better rate than what we're
looking at 2.48 when you look over 30 40
years that really accumulates into
quite an added amount of money in
someone's account
and I'm just curious as to if other
states are
that low or where the median is among
states that are doing this and if you
could get some of those figures it would
be helpful
I I can I mean the question there is
will 2.48 be enough
because
what you're looking at is not the cost
to run the pension plan which is the
2.48 it's will that be enough to make
sure that that employee can retire
because the employer doesn't want people
working at 70.
um and and the employee doesn't
necessarily want to work till 70. and
many retire
you know they can plan to work to pass
65 but you know a lot there's a lot of
people that exit the workforce for a
variety of reasons earlier yes and that
shows up in Social Security claiming
and that's my concern Madam chair is yes
whether or not we have enough money
going into an account we have an account
benefit plan at a low cost to employers
and to give another plan that may not be
as beneficial to the employees and
that's why I'd like this information so
it will be good information to have and
uh I I don't know who I'll inquire where
we could get this because right now we
look at it and and our pitch for people
to voluntarily join the plan and we have
just just over 40 percent of all
full-time employees contribute sending
nearly a million dollars every paycheck
of their own money right we'll look at
we'll get our researcher to find out
what other pla what other states offer
in their plans and one comment about
um pension costs
um this this uh legislation talks about
um people rolling money that they have
in the Deferred benefit the fine Benefit
Plan into the defined contribution plan
like a new worker like oh I don't you
know I've been here two years
I mean that is possible
um but I think that may come with a cost
so if you left the state after three
years you're not vested you have no
entitlement to State money in the
pension plan you only you can roll out
your contributions and the interest
that's accrued you can roll that tax
with no tax consequences into the Divine
contribution plan or another retirement
vehicle so I'm assuming that that's what
the bill is talking about
so it actually is something I don't see
it anywhere in the amendment but it was
part of the intention that the I just
think that so you would
you would do that it would make sense
for an individual say under five years
but then then it would make less sense
as you get closer and closer to a
guaranteed benefit
um but I think there's a there would be
a cost associated with that even though
the employee exits the system in their
the quote unquote cost would stop that
may
that may interrupt but it was just a
uh well thank you
excuse me representative Schmidt we've
got you're getting some feedback
somewhere
how about no
goalie what are you doing with this
system over here okay anyway so you you
just got done saying there would be a
something cost involved and I didn't
hear get you
I'm sorry I was just suggesting that
there might be a further cost to the
pension plan if you allowed employees
who were like new employees say three
years in and they go no I want to go to
the defined contribution plan I want to
pull my money out if you allowed that
and I think that would take specific
legislation
um that they're early withdrawal with
their money and interest might be an
additional cost to the pension plan can
I just Carlin is about to say that say
something about that
say that that's an example of the type
of conduit we need the actor to look at
that and alert us to what I was saying
it's you know it looks okay but they may
be some devils in the detail but that's
a good example okay yes and
and it's probably a secondary second
level effect as opposed to the primary
effects of
so it's just a quick quick question this
is going to the subcommittee why yes of
course and uh you're absolutely correct
but we're beating it to death today uh
so are you going to be available for the
subcommittee yes
thank you representative Gould thank you
this is just really quick
um did I hear you say something about
employees can choose to switch over
would that be part of this too
that existing employees would get to
switch over to them there is a line in
here that that's what I read was the
intent that if you were
you know a new employee already in the
uh pension system and you go hey I want
to take advantage of that defined
contribution the pilot example
representative blackis you have an
answer to that I couldn't find it myself
I'll I'll have to dig through it to get
the exact line and if it's not in there
it's OLS left it out we've been we're
not the only people having problems with
them the intent and what would be in
anything we'd really want to get through
is that
um
this is It's on page two line 30. okay
thank you thank you madam chair for
finding it for me um the it's I mean I
don't know what this thing is about a
new employee it doesn't have to be a new
employee so any eligible employee which
would be a state
um
you know
employee under the mean of employee in
the pension system which would not
include teachers or any of the group two
people
once if this went into effect an
existing employee no matter how long
they'd worked there could choose
to move over to the defined contribution
plan now if they've been in for a long
time it may not make Financial sense but
um they could do it
follow up
if that's the case what would the impact
be on the existing system if a large
portion of the employees
existing employees decided to make the
switch uh Mr Carlin said that let me
Mr Carlin said that you know they'd have
to have the actuaries look at it all I
can say is that at least this for this
initial take it's just state employees
who are not teachers or group two none
of the municipalities so
they'll have to look into it but the
number is not huge
thank you very much Madam chairman
I'll see we'll all see you in the
subcommittee goes to work Mr Moore
Madam chair members of the committee
thanks the opportunity to speak here
today for the record my name is Greg
Moore and I am the state director for
Americans for Prosperity in New
Hampshire and I'm here today testifying
and support of House Bill 559
but I'd like to offer a different
perspective I could certainly repeat
what others have heard and I know how
much legislators love redundant
testimony so I'll skip that uh and just
focus on coming at it from someone who
worked at a state agency for four years
and then worked for the New Hampshire
house
things crackling a little bit but move
further away
I think it might be the speaker
okay is that better thanks uh I'll just
give you a great example when I was
working at Health and Human Services I
was working with an employee who had
been there for a little over eight years
and I went to meet him at his cubicle
and on his screensaver it had a
countdown clock which had one year and
about eight months of course I didn't
recognize intuitively what it was so I
asked him what's this he said he said
that's when I hit my 10-year anniversary
and I can leave
so so just think from from the
perspective of of an employee who has
taken this job and it's particularly
true now uh I think we heard seven seven
or eight years ago there was a study
that showed that Millennials changed
jobs on average once every 18 months now
I followed up on that that's that's
grown so the good news is Millennials
are staying in their jobs longer the bad
news is that the Gen ziers who are the
now college graduates have been even
shorter Runway that's typically around
16 to 17 months so it seems like people
are staying in jobs longer and longer
and the idea of a defined benefit
contribution is great for the employer
in the sense that it creates a strong
incentive for employees to stay it's a
great retention tool however right now
having a defined defined benefit program
is a is a recruitment
detriment so what was it what was a
great retention tool is now a recruit
recruitment detriment and I think we see
that from the numbers that uh that
representative the sponsor I can't say
representative McGuire here it's the
sponsor put forward in showing just the
absolute number of employees who don't
make it to vesting and when you when you
have a situation where you have probably
I don't know maybe three quarters of
your people not making it to vesting I
think that's a sign that your overall
retirement strategy isn't working
and I think that that would be good if
we if if we could sort of get that broke
those numbers broken down by by state
and by by Municipal and County Employees
so that we could see specifically at the
state level
what what number of people who are of
new hires are actually making it to
having a vested retirement system and I
think that's probably the greatest
indication of whether the system is
working or not is if you have a very
small number of people are actually
making it to getting their vested uh
vested dollars by the way I did not
invest I did not serve 10 years of
unbroken service with the state but but
uh but I will say I will I will say that
that having a functional retirement
system is a critical role in terms of a
strong recruitment strategy
people entering the workforce now are
just much savvier about these things
than perhaps I was when I started my
career and I know a number of a number
of people my contemporaries we just
weren't as Savvy about these sort of
things
probably because almost everybody was on
a defined benefit program so people
weren't thinking about the Alternatives
but now with the prevalence of 401K
plans new employees are looking at that
and when I talk to Commissioners when I
talk to Commissioners across I'm friends
with a number of the state Commissioners
they'll tell you that the number one
problem is finding good people
but if you cross the board you talk to
State Commissioners finding good people
and the second thing the brain drains so
the their senior employees who have all
the knowledge and skill are leaving and
they're not bringing in that new group
of employees or who need to come in and
fill and grow that void and the
consequence of that is that is that
state agencies are farming more work out
to Consultants as opposed to in-house
into work and I think that having a
retirement system that benefits uh new
employees and is focused on on helping
the state's recruiting strategy I think
has other benefits that will be that
will go down the line across state
government so that was my point I don't
I I support a lot of the earlier
testimony but I don't want to be
redundant so I'll just stick with that
and one last point I'll make that uh
that I think we uh people are investing
some effort into looking at the
long-term aspect of the state's unfunded
liability I know that the legislation to
to legalize cannabis which was voted out
of committee today I believe 70 percent
of the revenues from that from from
those those funds go to the state's
retirement system so I I think it's
important to understand that that there
are people who are actively considering
and trying to figure out and work
through this unfunded liability so I'd
be happy to answer any questions
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
well we have and I think we heard it in
the governor's address too an issue of
filling jobs
um
would you not agree one of the bigger
issues is
state pay versus benefits and I think
that was addressed also in the
governor's speech increasing pay by 10
percent
I would say I would say that it's a lot
of things new employees some people look
for great benefits I mean as someone
who's hired people and you go talking to
them about you know what they are
looking for as far as a compensation
package it's all over the map some
people are really looking towards what's
your 401k match do you have a 401k match
and uh and and I'll tell you that that
pay is definitely one of them there are
some people are motivated that's that's
the number one factor others are focused
more on benefits but I think that we
have to look at the totality of the
package that we're offering that's going
to have the impact on the overall
ability to meet your recruiting goals
thank you and just one more question
seeing you brought up the pay match in
401k
do you know what the average pay match
is for corporations out there is it
anywhere near 2.48 percent
it's usually higher
thank you madam chair members of the
committee I am Drew Klein I'm president
of the Josiah Bartlett Center for Public
Policy New Hampshire's free market Think
Tank I want to try to avoid a lot of the
duplication here but make some of the
points that we've
um come across when looking at this
issue so Governor sununu as
representative goalie stated has made a
an attempt in the budget to invest in
the future Workforce of New Hampshire by
increasing pay across the board by 10
percent
raising wages as I think we all agree
we'll likely have a positive effect on
recruitment putting new hires into a
Divine contribution retirement plan
would have a similar effect
the state's outdated underfunded pension
plan is really not an attraction to
younger people who tend to Value
portability more than having a
guaranteed defined benefit and we know
this from polling and research done on
younger workers
now it's been said in here and
representative
um well sponsor Maguire mentioned it
there was a Bureau of Labor Statistics
study showing that people changed their
jobs
um 12 times throughout their career that
was a study of baby boomers
we know that that is shrinking and
shrinking we've gone from about changing
your job about every three and a third
years to 2.7 years and now we're going
down and down down to less than two
years younger workers particularly gen Z
have no intention whatsoever and staying
at a job for 10 years most of them
what about public employees well we have
some research on that as well Pew
research surveyed public employees in
2016.
and ask them these very questions they
found that 60 percent of employees under
the age of 30 did not expect to say with
stay with their current employer until
retirement
so it's not surprising then
that those employers those employees
under age 30 told Pew their top priority
for their retirement plans is the
ability to take their savings with them
when changing jobs
HP 559 would offer this flexibility
by enrolling new employees into the
defined contribution plan
the University of system of New
Hampshire already has a defined
contribution plan for its employees so
there's no reason to fear offering one
for new state employees
UNH system schools actually advertise
and boast about their defined
contribution report retirement plan go
to Keene State's website for example and
right there under benefits says Keene
State offers quote generous defined
contribution retirement plan
defined contribution plans are in fact a
default plan in higher education now as
well as the private sector
they're growing in the public sector too
46 States plus the District of Columbia
offer a defined contribution plan for
employees either as the primary
retirement plan or a supplemental plan
19 States offer a defined contribution
plan as their primary retirement plan
and though these are not all Southern
States western states there's they
include you know Ohio Connecticut
Michigan Pennsylvania Rhode Island
and some people you might hear will
blame defined contribution plans for a
decline in America's retirement savings
but a 2015 study by the center for
Retirement Research at Boston College
concluded that quote people are not
accumulating less as a result of the
shift from defined benefit to defined
contribution plans
the truth is simply that defined benefit
plans like New Hampshire's are on the
way out for good reason
it's all but inevitable that these plans
over promise and under deliver by Design
they create incentives to promise
unrealistically High benefits while
shaving contributions below the level
needed to meet those unrealistic
expectations
and in the public sector
Define benefits plans inevitably oblige
taxpayers to cover any gap between the
promise benefits and the contributions
required to create those benefits
enrolling new state employees in a
defined contribution plan would be a
better deal for the taxpayers the state
and new employees
employees would finally be able to
accumulate retirement savings that they
own and control from Year One
which is a hugely valuable benefit that
younger employees want but cannot get in
the current system
this would help attract younger people
to the state to state government
would set realistic expectations for new
employees going forward and protect
taxpayers
and some we no longer have a 21st or
rather a 20th century Workforce
so we shouldn't Force new hires into a
20th century retirement plan
and to give a little bit of context and
rep goalies earlier question about
contributions
um
the employer contribution on these
defined contribution plans around the
country ranges from around three percent
in some states to about 14 percent in
other states so it's a big range
it's a policy decision that States make
happy to take any questions
can you tell us what the states are that
are offering three percent and which
ones are in 14 I I could read you from a
report from last year I don't know that
that would be a great use of time but
I'm sure this is available Florida just
to give an example Florida had a really
low system they were contributing free
in a third percent at the state level
and only three percent at the employee
level they fixed that they realize that
was a bad mix
um but I'm we can get this number to you
foreign
thank you for taking my question you
referenced the university system having
a generous defined contribution plan do
you know what the rates are for employee
ease employers
uh sorry no I don't know that off top of
my head
I'm sure somebody in the room would have
it
Madam Chef we could get that I'd like to
see the difference
foreign
chairman committee members thank you for
hearing me today my name is Ray Chadwick
I'm from Bedford New Hampshire
Pittsburgh how's this this better I hope
um I'm chairman of Granite State
taxpayers I've sent in some formal
written testimony earlier I'll briefly
reprise that is the point being that in
the private sector because of the Orissa
and other things like that Define
benefit plans are almost non-existent at
this point in time so anyone who is an
employee who has access to a defined
contribution plan he or she is already
accepting the risk if I will call it
that of the marketplace markets go up
markets go down those kinds of things
happen
um that same risk applies to the funds
in our retirement system so
that can go up and go down over time the
point I would raise I did raise in that
thing is that our current system
requires all of those private sector
employees
to indemnify
government employees from the market
risk that all those other people have to
bear already
so
the cost of the system and the unfunded
liability is the result of decisions
made by legislators before you
decisions on 20 years 30 years what
assumptions on return on investment what
decisions made on providing costs of
living analysis adjustments or whatever
they may be
The Proposal here is can be properly
viewed I think as moving that risk
from
basically the state government which
ultimately means the taxpayers to new
employees people have testified that
indeed
it's beneficial for new employees to
feel that they are not
bound to the job shackle to the job and
position because they're waiting to be
vested my experience I started
employment in 1968 my employer at the
time offered a defined benefit and a
defined pre-tax contribution they
matched parts of it plan and I went
through that eventually left the company
obviously it didn't take anything out of
the pension plan but I could take all
the money contributed by myself and the
company matches
over time I rolled that into
contributions by other employers I
finally actualized on the defined
benefit plan which was to find benefit
there was no such thing as cost of
living or inflation adjustments
the check I got in 2006 is the exact
same amount I get today
the check I get today can only buy
67 percent of what the check in 2007
would do meanwhile the money that went
into my defined contribution plan which
has been reinvested currently with the
Trust Company
um I've been drawing on that since the
same time 2006 in an amount
approximately 50 percent more
than the defined benefit amount
and that has not only paid me that money
about four percent every year since but
has accumulated 10 percent more value
over time
the reason I bring this up is to support
the concept of basically the
taking new employees giving them that
option of potentially having well having
portability and the ability to control
their own money we've talked a bit about
risk it's true that there is risk when
you go into the market depending on when
you get in and where you are now but
that is the state of the economy for
virtually all private employees in this
state and the question here I think
before us is whether new employees
should start transitioning to such a
situation
the fact that we have a six
approximately six billion dollar
unfunded liability reflects all those
decisions of the past
and
it has not worked well I guess is the
way I would say it so this would unsolve
the state from an ongoing source of
Financial Risk
basically absolve the taxpayers at large
from that source of Financial Risk so we
support the the bill in its amended form
and I'll take any questions if you will
thank you
good you all want to leave too
I agree thank you very much thank you
very much for listening